[musique]
Messieurs, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Serview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement Faracos
Roavar ? Pierre connaissa Fara.
Je suis enseignant émérite à l'école de
hautes études en sciences sociales. J'ai
été directeur d'études,
ce qui signifie enfin pompeusement
professeur. J'ai enseigné là-bas.
Je suis d'origine iranienne, je suis
franco-iranien, je suis iranien pour les
Français et français pour les Iraniens.
Et dans c'est entre deux, je me retrouve
parfaitement parce que euh mon identité
aussi entre les deux, j'écris beaucoup
plus en français qu'en Perant et
maintenant un peu en anglais. Mais
disons que
je n'ai aucun état d'âme dans
[raclement de gorge] cette identité
flottante. Voilà.
Pierre connaît ça. Est-ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succintement ?
D'accord. Ben écoute, moi je suis ancien
au fonctionnaire maintenant retraité
[raclement de gorge] et j'ai fait
différents métiers. J'ai changé tous les
5 ans, c'està-dire j'étais un
fonctionnaire instable. Voilà. J'ai
passé l'essentiel de ma vie
professionnelle dans l'administration au
ministère de la défense où j'ai fait
tout sauf de l'administration. Et puis
depuis ce depuis que je suis en
retraite, j'ai créé.
Tu as vendu des armes ?
Oui oui bien sûr. Ouais,
on en reparlera. Ouais.
Aujourd'hui, on va parler géopolitique,
on va parler religion, fanatisme,
guerre, guerre de religion et tout un
tas de sujets.
Qui est-ce qui veut commencer à me
parler de quoi ? Alors, chose, on devait
faire l'interview hier. Pierre a eu deux
trois petites broutilles à régler. Merci
Pierre, on est content. Pierre, on parle
de quoi aujourd'hui ? Écoute, moi j'ai
proposé qu'on parle de religion et
violence parce que une chose qui m'a
frappé moi et qui m'a amené à écrire sur
ce sujet là, c'est dans les années 80
tout le monde constatait un retour du
religieux en disant mais oui, les
pratiques et cetera et cetera. Et moi ce
qui me frappe c'est que depuis la
décennie 90 et même en grande partie
dans la décennie 80 a commencé à
apparaître un radicalisme religieux,
c'est-à-dire des gens qui considéraient
que leur vision de la religion était la
bonne et c'est-à-dire cette vision
radicale était à la fois à tourner
contre les mauvais croyants de la même
religion ou contre les les mécréants,
c'est-à-dire ceux des autres religions.
Et ce [raclement de gorge] qui me paraît
étonnant, c'est que nous nous focalisons
sur le radicalisme musulman, mais en
fait, il y a des radicalismes partout
dont certains ont des versions
officielles.
Et celui qui m'a le plus frappé, c'est
celui des néovangéliques américains.
[raclement de gorge] Les néo
évangéliques américains, c'est un
exemple intéressant parce que ça se
situe dans l'ère chrétienne et donc
c'est ceux-là qui ont poussé George
Bouche à aller faire la guerre à l'Irak
et à l'Afghanistan avec une idée qui
était totalement théologique,
c'est-à-dire que le
le Messie allait revenir,
non ? C'est-à-dire que pour que le
Messie revienne, il fallait que le grand
Israël soit constitué. Donc pour faire
le grand Israël, il fallait détruire un
de ces principaux obstacles qui était le
qui était en particulier le l'Irak de
Saddam Hussein. Alors, il y a un épisode
qui est très drôle, c'est que justement,
tu sais que pour les juifs qui ont la
même vision, c'est-à-dire que le grand
Israël est un préalable retour du
Messie, mais il y a une petite
divergence théologique entre les juifs
et les chrétiens, c'est que pour les
juifs, le Messie n'est jamais venu. Pour
les chrétiens, il est venu une fois.
Alors, comme Netaniaou a quand même
beaucoup besoin des néovangéliques
américains un beau jour où la discussion
tournait un peu en autre boudin, il leur
a dit écoutez, le jour où il viendra, on
lui posera une seule question. Est-ce
que c'est la première fois ? parce que
c'est la deuxième fois que tu viens et
c'est comme ça qu' c'est sorti de la
difficulté. Ils sont donc restés bons
amis.
Fara, tu travailles un peu sur le terror
si on peut se tutoyer.
[raclement de gorge]
Oui, sur le terrorisme, sur le
djihadisme. Euh en même temps,
[raclement de gorge] le problème
essentiel c'est que ce phénomène, on le
sait historiquement,
il date des années à partir de
l'invasion par la Russie de
l'Afghanistan.
Ensuite [raclement de gorge]
avec les problèmes que ça a soulevé,
ensuite la révolution iranienne 1979 si
vous voulez c'est la date charnière. H
il y a la révolution iranienne, il y a
l'invasion de l'Afghanistan par l'Union
soviétique et il y a l'attaque de la
mosquée, la grande mosquée de la Mecque
par des islamistes radicaux. Donc c'est
vraiment la date où on voit bien qu'il y
a un certain nombre de phénomènes
nouveaux et qui apparaissent. Et dans
ces phénomènes nouveaux qui
apparaissent, évidemment dans pour ce
qui est de l'Afghanistan, euh
la complicité de l'Union soviétique est
évidente. Ensuite, on voit bien que il y
a une autre date charnière, c'est 2001
avec
[raclement de gorge] les attaques des
tours jumelles de Pentagone et cetera
aux États-Unis. le 11 septembre 2001. Et
ensuite, il y a une autre date
charnière, c'est l'invasion de l'Irak
par
George Bouche et la constitution d'un
noyau dur de l'État islamique qui sera
l'État islamique de la Syrie et du
[raclement de gorge] Levent
par la suite en 2014, juin 2014 si mes
souvenirs sont exactas. euh et la
constitution du djihadisme qui a fait
quand même beaucoup de dégâts dans le
monde musulman, mais aussi en Europe et
et plus particulièrement en terme de
nombre de victimes en France.
Euh par conséquent, il y a ce phénomène
de violence lié à [raclement de gorge]
la religion qui est, je crois, assez
bien circonscriptible
historiquement. Mais cela étant et on
sait très bien que ces phénomènes ne se
réduisent pas à des dates, qu'il y a un
arrière-plan, qu'il y a des formes
de radicalisation et que si on regarde
maintenant de manière synchronique
ce qui se passe dans le monde, on voit
très bien qu'il y a en Europe et en
Occident une sorte de reflux du
djihadisme. En nombre de victimes, il y
a de moins en moins, il y a très peu par
rapport à 2015, 2016, 2017.
Et on voit qu'il y a d'autres formes de
radicalisme
laïque ou religieux qui intervient, qui
apparaissent. Par exemple, en Inde, on
voit bien qu'il y a une forme de
radicalisme contre les musulmans par les
hindus.
On voit très bien qu'il y a aux
États-Unis avec
Trump par exemple, il y en a eu juste à
la fin de son mandat cette
radicalisation qui s'est transformé en
une sorte d'attaque de
[raclement de gorge]
congrès si mes souvenirs sont exa à la
fin de son mandat et donc violence. Et
par la suite, on voit bien qu'il y a
aussi des formes de radicalisation
laïque ou chrétienne en Europe.
Politique, voire politique.
Exactement. Et donc on est dans un dans
une sorte d'imbroli
entre le laïque, le religieux, l'islam,
l'hindouisme, le christianisme, le
judaïsme et par conséquent dans ce
on est dans ce phénomène à mon avis et
qu'il faut analyser un peu plus finement
mais dont les [raclement de gorge]
chevaux est quand même quasiment
inextricable quand on regarde de loin.
Alors
oui, mais quand on le regarde de près,
si tu veux, on croit qu'une crise est
spécifique. Moi, ce qui m'a frappé,
c'est justement la généralisation de ces
pratiques. [raclement de gorge] Par
exemple, on chez les chez les
bouddhistes, bon, tu sais que pour nous
les bouddhistes, c'est Mathieu, Ricard,
le Dalil Lama, le Nirvana, tout ce que
tu veux. Bon, en fait, il y a au Myanmar
un épisode historique extrêmement
intéressant. Quand à l'époque où c'était
colonie anglaise, les anglais d'un grand
cynisme faisaient venir des travailleurs
du Bangladesh pour les sur les
plantations de thé. Bon, quand il y a eu
l'indépendance du Myanmar, les
bouddhistes ont dit "Non, ces gens-là,
ils sont pas de chez nous." et ils ont
fait ils en ont fait des apatrides. Ce
type s'appelle les roying donc ce sont
des pauvres types vraiment c'était le
les ouvriers agricoles. Ils en ont fait
des apatri et puis depuis c'est exprimé
une espèce de radicalisme bouddhiste.
Tout dit bouddhiste, c'est pas ça qu'on
connaît avec un type sur lequel Barbad
Schreder a fait un film très intéressant
qui s'appelle le vénérable W. C'est
viratou. Et ce type tient un discours
qui ici le ferait condamné contre les
musulmans. C'est-à-dire que il il
pourrait pas tenir le même discours ici.
Bref, les rouingas, juste une
parenthèse, les rouingas, je crois que
leur sous-sol
et plein d'hydrocarburant. Ah plein, tu
sais, c'est le concept de plein
hydrocarbure est une espèce d'art. Ça
s'écrit en un seul mot, hein. Je sais
pas exactement. Mais en tout cas, ce qui
est vrai, c'est que c'est pas simplement
pour des raisons économiques, c'est
vraiment des raisons religieuses. Et
c'est ça qui est intéressant, c'est que
avec la révolution iranienne, on s'est
rendu compte que le religieux pouvait
être un facteur politique alors que
nous, on était en pleine période de
laïcisation. Quand je se dis, j'ai les
les les comment dire les les les
iraniens d'opposition qui vivaient en
France nous expliquaient les mots là, on
les connaît, vous inquiétez pas, on va
se les mettre dans la poche. Je connais
la fin de l'histoire. Et donc les
royingas sont intéressants parce que
cela personne ne s'intéresse à eux. Et
alors comme les les bouddhistes les pour
les chass et qui se retrouvent dans la
zone inondable du delta, le Bangladéchi,
ils ont pas envie de les récupérer et
les pauvres types bon et on narrive pas
à mobiliser BHL sur le sujet parce qu'il
y a pas d'effet médiatique. pha avant
qu'on rentre dans le dur sur les
questions de d'attentat potentiel au J
de radicalisation après le le 7 octobre
de radicalisation après la surréreaction
d'Israël ou le le la la la façon très
spéciale de d'appliquer une guerre
Farais
que vous me parliez de la révolution
iranienne.
Quel est le dernier souvenir que vous
avez
de Théan
en fait
après la révolution qui c'est fait en
mais moi je suis resté en Iran, j'étais
dans un centre de recherche
jusqu'en
10 11. Oui.
Et donc je suis resté plus de 10 ans en
Iran. Et ce qu'il y avait de bon,
c'était que comme c'était la révolution
et l'instabilité, le directeur du centre
changeait tous les 6 mois [rires] avant
qu'il sache ce qu'on faisait et il
changeait. Et donc moi, j'étais très
libre. Je travaillais beaucoup sur ma
thèse d'État en France et j'avais une
présence physique mais pas une présence
perceptible. Avant cela, j'étais à une
université qui venait d'être fondée par
le chat, l'université d'Amadan, qui euh
où il y avait quand même la fine fleur
de beaucoup euh d'intellectuels et de
scientifiques euh euh iraniens ou même
quelquefois étrangers. Par exemple, moi
j'étais avec des gens qui avaient fait
des Français qui avaient fait leurs
études à l'école normale supérieure à
Paris. Donc il était allé sous le chat
parce que ça ça on payait bien et puis
il y avait quand même un sentiment que
ça pouvait avoir un effet.
Par conséquent [raclement de gorge]
euh euh l'Iran quand je l'ai quitté
ensuite je l'ai rejoint encore par la
suite sous Ratami. Ratami si vous voulez
[raclement de gorge]
il a pu avoir deux mandats de 4 ans et
pendant cette période il y avait une
sorte de libéralisation en Iran au moins
au niveau des médias de l'information de
la discussion de débat. Et donc euh
[raclement de gorge]
je suis allé la dernière fois que
j'étais en j'ai été en Iran, ça a été en
euh 2009
où il y a eu euh [raclement de gorge] un
mouvement euh contre le candidat imposé
par
la droite conservatrice iranienne.
Et ce mouvement comme moi je suis
sociologue,
j'ai travaillé beaucoup avec Alain
Touren sous sa direction et donc comme
mouvement social cela m'intéressait mais
à partir de 2009, j'ai pas pu y aller
pour des raisons que tout le monde sait
à savoir que si j'y vais, je peux y
aller mais vraisemblablement je ne
pourrais pas retourner. Euh et comme
j'ai d'autres livres en plan euh et mon
projet de vie n'est pas de passer le
restant de mes jours en prison. Euh j'y
ai renoncé mais disons que je suis en
contact très direct avec l'Iran et mes
souvenirs euh sont des souvenirs qui se
renouvellent beaucoup parce que j'ai des
amis euh qui travaillent sur dans les
sciences sociales, qui ont euh un
métier, qui sont médecins, qui sont
vraiment euh des
constructeurs, enfin bon
des architectes. Et donc je suis au
courant de ce qui se passe avec ce
sentiment que bon, il y a
[raclement de gorge]
un rissement du régime, que le régime
s'est transformé en une sorte de
totalitarisme
euh qui réprime les femmes. D'ailleurs,
le dernier mouvement, c'était le
mouvement Massa. ce qu'on appelle le
mouvement massa, c'estàd du nom de de la
jeune fille qui a trouvé la mort dans
dans service [raclement de gorge] de
répression du régime. Et moi, ce
mouvement m'a profondément intéressé et
j'y ai consacré un livre en français et
un autre livre en anglais qui va sortir.
Le livre en français s'appelle
euh la jeunesse
iranienne. La jeunesse l'Iran de point
la jeunesse démocratique contre l'État
prédateur.
Ça ça a été publié il y a un an et demi
euh [raclement de gorge]
et je et mon livre va sortir en anglais
dans dans en mois d'octobre
sur ce phénomène. Donc il y a le
mouvement Massa et là je rejoins ce que
disait Pierre à savoir que ce que j'ai
appelé enfin pour le titre du livre
c'est la révolte contre la théocratie.
Il y a une dimension économique,
politique, culturelle, sociale et
cetera, mais il y a une dimension
religieuse.
Il y a les jeunes par exemple qui sont
pour une culture de la joie contre la
culture de la tristesse mais en même
temps ils sont contre la répression en
même et d'un autre côté ce qui se passe
en Iran n'est pas aussi exceptionnel
qu'on ne le pense en terme de répression
en Arabie Saoudite
d'une certaine manière en Égypte
dans [raclement de gorge] les pays du
Golf
en Israël et cetera. Il y a des formes
de répression qui sont extrêmement
importantes et en en France et en Europe
et en Occident, j'ai l'impression qu'il
y a double poids double mesure.
C'est-à-dire que par exemple quand on
dénonce l'Iran, on a entièrement raison.
Mais par exemple pour l'Arabie Saoudite,
pour les autres pays de la région, pour
l'Égypte et cetera,
on y met un bémol. Non pas qu'on le
fasse exprès, mais disons qu'il y a
aussi un phénomène euh d'appartenance
vraisemblablement subjective à ces
phénomène de la part de certains
journalistes. Mais en même temps, il
doit y avoir aussi des pressions euh
médiatiques. Je veux dire que euh moi,
j'aime bien qu'on dénonce la répression
en Iran, mais j'aime aussi bien qu'on
dénonce les autres
formes de répression dans d'autres pays
de la région qui ne sont pas plus
libéraux sur ce plan. comme en France
avec les gilets jaunes
par exemple par exemple enfin bon on il
faut qu'il y ait quand même une sorte de
justice dans la dénonciation or j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a souvent double
poid double mesure
c'est-à-dire qu'on instrumentalise la
dénonciation
et il y a une instrumentalisation en
même temps. Je crois qu'il y a une sorte
de sympathie ou d'antipathie
après tout l'Arabie Saoudite est quand
même l'allié de l'Occident
[grognement] par rapport à l'Iran.
Mais oui, l'allié économiquement
intéressante.
On leur vend des arbres, on leur vend
d'autres choses, on leur prend du
pétrole. Bref, il y a une dissymétrie
dans la manière dont on traite en
quelque sorte en terme de répression ces
sociétés.
Alors Pierre Pierre ou ou Phara la cette
disymétrie, elle vient de quoi ? Elle
vient du traitement médiatique, elle
vient du traitement médiatique imposé
par des politiques, c'est-à-dire une
autocensure du journaliste ou pour aller
sous l'information du robinet, aller
dans le sens du courant du pouvoir en
place. Pierre Fara, vous rebondissez et
après Pharaends
après Fara, je voudrais vous poser la
question
sur le voile. Les iraniennes veulent
enlever le voile et ici en France il y
en a certains qui veulent dire que le
voile c'est bien.
Après Fara, je t'en donne la parole
Pierre.
Moi, je voudrais te attirer l'attention
sur la formation de nos élites parce que
ça vient en partie expliquer ce que
disait Farad.
Quand tu fais la trajectoire courte
classe prépa, normale subsence pot et NA
grand corps cabinet
ce qui est la la 80 % de la composition
des cabinets
du ministre.
Pas tout de suite hein, il fait après il
y a un processus tu veux qui est un peu
plus compliqué. Mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que le terau qui va aider le le
politique à faire ses décisions est un
terro humain qui en fait se caractérise
par le fait que justement en ayant fait
que des études, ils ne connaissent que
ils connaissent pas le monde, ils
connaissent un peu leur pays mais avec
modération. Bon, ça veut donc dire que
si tu veux, il y a une pensée qui est au
centré. La Terre est plate, Paris en est
le centre, le 5e, 6e, 7e arrondissement
en est effectivement le la le nombril.
Le tout est encerné par ce que j'ai
appelé le complexe militaire
intellectuel puisque tu sais que tu n'es
un intellectuel français respectable que
si tu habites dans le 5e, 6e, 7e. Bon,
farade, vous habitez où ?
Moi, j'ai habité à Créteille et
maintenant j'habite à Châton Malabri.
Mais je ne fais pas partie des
intellectuels en vue.
Ah bah non. Bah non. Bah attends, faut
pas péter plus haut que son cul quand
même. Faut pas exagérer. Non, ce qui est
ce que je veux dire, c'est que tu vois
ce situe ce site ce cette centralité de
l'intellectuel français quelque chose
qui est très spécifique à notre société.
Je vous en cite un exemple. Le
début du 20e, l'Occident est triomphant.
Révolution industrielle, on a colonisé
la planète et cetera et cetera. Bref,
première guerre mondiale, on fait 20
millions de morts et on remet ça la fois
suivante, 50 millions de morts. Que les
intellectuels étaient critiques à
l'égard de ce système qui était
colonialiste, qui était guerrier, tout
ce que tu veux et cetera, mais en étant
totalement aveugle sur ce qui se passait
de l'autre côté, c'est-à-dire en
adhérant à des utopies qui pouvaient
être des utopies laïques pour ceux qui
s'étaient devenus fascistes ou des ou
communistes. Puis ensuite aujourd'hui,
on va avoir des mecs qui vont adhérer à
des utopies religieuses. Si tu veux, ce
mouvement de de dénonciation était
compréhensible. Mais quand je dis que la
Terre est plate et qu'on en est le
centre, je vais vous en citer deux
exemples. Euh
on fait le en 48, on crée l'ONU. On va
enfin trouver l'organisation
internationale qui va empêcher la
guerre. On adopte la charte
internationale des droits de l'homme.
Charte internationale des droits de
l'homme, c'est les 5 m permanents,
c'est-à-dire la France et la
Grande-Bretagne qui sont les deux
grandes puissances coloniales de la
planète. C'est les États-Unis qui sont
racistes et ségrégationnistes. C'est
l'URSS de Staline et la Chine de Changai
Cheek. Donc tu vois en terme de
politique étrangère, faut bien
comprendre que c'est faites ce que je
dis, faites pas ce que je fais.
Un autre exemple pour terminer
là-dessus, on fait le procès de
Nuremberberg. Procès de Nuremberberg, on
va accuser les élites nazises d'avoir
déclenché la guerre, d'avoir fait des
massacres, d'avoir fait la choa, d'avoir
fait des camps de concentration, de la
déportation et cetera. Pendant le procès
de Nuremberberg, on reprend la
recolonisation, c'estàdire les émeutes
de cétif en Algérie avec revendication
de l'indépendance 3000 morts seulement
bombardement d' Fong le l'amiral
d'Argentlieu qui est un compagnon de la
libération 6000 morts à fond encore une
fois sur des revendications
indépendantistes c'est-à-dire on est
capable de recoloniser alors qu'on est
en train de faire le procès et on va
utiliser dans les guerres de
décolonisation les mêmes méthodes que
celles pour lesquelles on a condamné les
naas mais nous on va pas repasser devant
le tribunal international donc tu vois
comment finalement
se construit ce de poids de mesure et le
cas de l'Iran est particulièrement
intéressant. J'en termine là-dessus.
Quand il y a la révolution iranienne,
les gardiens de la révolution
envahissent l'ambassade américaine. On
se demande pourquoi les Américains avent
encore une ambassade, mais enfin bref,
il se pensaient à l'abri de tout ça
quand ils en
des choses, ils trouvent d'ailleurs des
choses dans l'ambassade pas à piquer des
hans.
Alors justement il les américains
s'étaient probablement rendu compte
assez tard que effectivement ils vaient
mieux prendre ses précautions. Ils
avaient commencé à déchiqueter les
télégrammes bref mais ils avaient pas
tout fini. Donc quand les gardiens de la
révolution, tu me corriges he Farad si
je me raconte des bêtises, mais ils
trouvent donc ces ces trucs de papier,
ils vont les donner à des tisseuses de
tapis qui vont reconstituer des
documents. Ces documents montrant et ils
ont été publiés toutes les ingérences
que les Américains avaient fait à
l'époque du chat dans le gouvernement
iranien et cetera. Bref, mais comme en
même temps ils font prisonniers des
diplomates américains scandale,
convention de Vienne, voilà, c'est
normal les ces diplomates doivent être
protégés. Alors, tu te dis mais lequel
des deux aolé la convention de Vienne ?
les Américains avec leurs ingérences ou
les les
Iraniens avec leurs otages. Bref,
Saddam Hussein [raclement de gorge]
vient nous voir, il nous dit
"Écoutez-moi, si vous voulez, je peux
leur faire la guerre, mais vous me
garantissez que les armes et vous me
garantissez qu'il y aura pas d'embargo".
Alors, tu sais qu'end droit
international, quand il y a un conflit,
tous les fournisseurs d'armes
normalement doivent pratiquer un
embargo. Bon,
allez-y, mon ami, allez-y. Donc, il
déclenche la guerre. il déclenche la
guerre et on va réussir cette
performance extraordinaire, c'est qu'on
va mettre sous embargot l'agressé l'Iran
pour fournir des armes à l'agresseur
l'Irak. Donc, tu veux que je recommence
ou c'est pas la peine ? Tu vois ce que
je veux dire ? C'est-à-dire qu'on est
dans cette espèce de cynisme des
relations internationales dans
lesquelles il va falloir trouver des
excuses parce qu'on vaexliquer que c'est
pour libérer les oages américains, que
c'est un régime oppresseur et cetera.
Mais c'est pas les régimes oppresseurs
qui déclenchent les guerres. C'est pas
toujours cette seule scénario. On l'a vu
avec Bush après le 11 septembre, il
avait besoin de faire une guerre, il les
a déclenché sans difficulté. Merci
d'ailleurs à Dominic de Villepin de nous
avoir et Chirac de nous avoir évité
d'aller euh taper sur l'Irak. Un million
de morts de l'uranium appouvri un peu
partout euh et la propagation de de tout
un tas de choses.
Tu as raison de citer cet exemple parce
qu'aujourd'hui les gens qui veulent
faire passer Poutine devant la Cour
pénale internationale,
tu leur dis mais attendez, est-ce que
dans la salle d'attente il y a George
Bouche ? Mais non, c'est pas pareil.
Tony Blair
ou Tony Blair.
Oui. Oui. Mais je veux dire, il te dit
non, c'est pas pareil. C'est-à-dire, tu
vois, quand tu pars du postulat que
comme c'est démocrat des démocraties,
elles doivent pas être passé au
jugement,
c'est l'axe du bien.
Ah bah oui, c'est l'axe du bien. Farad,
est-ce que vous pouvez rebondir sur ce
qu'a dit Pierre concernant la révolution
et ensuite je voudrais votre point de
vue sur le voile ?
Oui, en fait, moi je crois que
[raclement de gorge]
le problème de double poids, double
mesure dont je parlais est évident dans
ces phénomènesl.
On [raclement de gorge] n'est pas dans
un monde équilibré où le droit se
distribuerait de manière équitable entre
différents pays. Il y en a qui sont plus
forts que d'autres et évidemment il ils
en ils en usent et donc
[raclement de gorge] d'une certaine
manière
lesquels lesquels sont plus forts et
lesquels en us.
La puissance hégémonique, les États-Unis
peut se permettre par exemple d'envahir
l'Irak qui sur le moment de l'invasion
après ça a été légalisé par les Nations
Unies par le Conseil de sécurité si mes
souvenirs sont exactas. Mais sur le
moment c'était illégal.
Non seulement c'était illégal, c'était
mensongé. Mais oui. Bon mais il je veux
dire illégal dans le sens qu'il y avait
euh aucune raison euh
légitime internationalement légalement
qui puisse justifier cette invasion. Bon
euh mais ils l'ont fait et personne
ensuite n'est venu leur demander euh en
quelque sorte la raison de cette
invasion ni les mettre en accusation
directement de manière de manière
efficace.
Je crois qu'ils ne reconnaissent pas le
la
non. Non mais mais même les pays qui
reconnaissent la haine n'ont pas fait
cela, n'ont pas n'ont pas mis en
accusation la puissance hégémonique.
D'ailleurs, c'est impossible de le faire
parce que on sait très bien que ils ont
le dernier mot. Enfin bon, bref, on
n'est pas dans un monde où
[raclement de gorge] la justice légale
et internationale s'imposerait à tout le
monde de manière équitable. Ça euh je
crois que
c'est pour ça que les bricks sont euh un
petit peu frileux avec tout ça. C'est
pour ça que les bricks se recentrent.
C'est pour ça que euh la Chine a décidé
de prendre le, si je peux me permettre
de parler avec un mot d'anglais, le lead
le le de de tout ça. effectivement euh
ils se rendent bien compte que ce n'est
pas au sein de ce système et qu'ils
peuvent s'affirmer et donc ils tentent
de reconstruire un système à côté mais
qui est tout aussi euh
tout aussi fondé sur euh le pouvoir et
la répression que l'autre système et
même si davantage vraisemblablement sur
certains points. Bref, on est dans un
monde où on parle de la justice
internationale, on parle du droit
international mais en réalité énormément
de choses échappent à cette justice et
ceux même qui ceux-là même qui jugent
sont vraiment intéressés par le système
comme le disait Pierre. Il y a quand
même, je sais pas moi, les États-Unis,
euh l'Angleterre, la France, la Chine,
euh bon, tous ces pays-là ont quand même
un point de vue euh très intéressé
par leurs propres intérêts, par leur
propre euh hégémonie, par leur propre
idéologie,
idéologie aussi qui vient en un sens
corroborer ces phénomènesl. Donc dans un
sens, on est dans ce monde injuste
mais qui par des raisons spécifiques,
peut en un sens incriminer un certain
nombre de régimes comme le nazisme qu'on
devrait incriminer. Je veux dire, mais
le problème essentiel c'est que il n'y a
pas que le nazisme et on sait bien que
la Russie soviétique aussi l'Union
soviétique enfin Staline a commis
vraiment
plusieurs millions
de meurtres et bon et que les États-Unis
en Irak ont tué quand même plusieurs
centaines de milliers de gens dont des
enfants indirectement ou directement.
Bon bref, on est dans ce monde-là et par
conséquent une vision purement comment
dire légaliste n'arrive absolument pas à
expliquer la complexité de ces
phénomènes là. Le voile Farade,
le voile. [raclement de gorge] Quand
quand quand vous voyez des femmes
voilées en France,
euh ça vous fait quoi ? Écoutez
[grognement]
moi, enfin je vous dis un peu mon point
de vue et après je sais très bien que
c'est un point de vue parmi d'autres qui
doit être discuté, remise en cause et
cetera.
Merci pour ces précautions oratoire.
Non mais c'est important parce que euh
je pense que la question du voile doit
être résolue au niveau des femmes.
Euh c'est-à-dire que c'est elles qui
doivent décider. Évidemment, on ne peut
pas se voiler entièrement parce que
comment comment voulez-vous qu'elle
décide quand vous avez une fraterie qui
leur impose de de s'habiller de piét en
cape ?
C'està-dire peut pas, je prends
l'exemple de l'Iran, il y a beaucoup de
femmes qui ne veulent pas porter le
voile en Iran et donc il y a une
répression contre ces femmes qui
refusent de porter le voile. D'ailleurs,
c'est à l'origine de ce mouvement
des femmes [raclement de gorge] contre
le pouvoir théocratique.
Euh elles ne contestent pas le voile en
soi. Elles ne disent pas il faut
interdire le voile.
Elles veulent le choix.
Elles veulent le choix. C'est-à-dire,
c'est moi qui dois décider en tant que
femme si oui ou non je dois porter le
voile. D'ailleurs, il y a beaucoup de
femmes qui portent le voile et qui sont
très connues en Iran même et qui ont
protesté contre l'imposition du voile
obligatoire. Donc c'est l'obligation de
porter le voile qui pose problème. On ne
doit pas imposer aux femmes au nom d'une
logique supérieure sacrée le fait de
porter ou de ne pas porter le voile.
Moi, je pense que le voile c'est un
phénomène qui relève des femmes et pour
lutter contre les excès du voilement
dans [raclement de gorge] les pays
occidentaux, je crois que la solution
frontale ne marche pas.
ne marche pas. Il faudrait d'autres
solutions.
Par exemple, la dérision, le fait de
faire en sorte qu'il y ait une mode
d'homme et de femmes qui porte le voile,
des formes d'expression qui en même
temps laissent la liberté de choix aux
femmes.
Est-ce que j'ai le droit de porter le
kilt en Iran ?
Le kilt ? Oui.
Non,
pas de kilt.
Enfin, personne jusqu'à présent ne l'a
porté, mais si on porte puisque ça
laisse entrevoir et les jambes euh
souvent disgracieuses des hommes, euh et
ben euh
c'est pas vrai. Pierre a des très belles
jambes.
Oui, c'est vrai.
Alors, [rires] alors évidemment euh
c'est interdit. D'ailleurs, il y a une
interdiction aussi pour les hommes. Euh
doivent pas trop montrer leurs bras.
Euh, ils ne peuvent pas porter des
bermudas.
Même quelquefois la cravate est
interdite que
ça c'est très bien ça.
Non mais c'est un critère d'identité
iranienne. Les iraniens venaient
toujours aux conférences internationale
sans cravate.
Extraordinaire.
Donc c'est vraiment il y a je crois que
là intervient ce qu'on pourrait appeler
la liberté de choix des femmes. Euh
est-ce que on doit interdire le voile ou
est-ce qu'on doit interdire
le dévoilement ? Là, je crois que c'est
les femmes elles-mêmes qui doivent
choisir, mais en quelque sorte, il faut
que ce soit un joint encadré. Par
exemple, le voile intégral ne laisse pas
entrevoir l'identité de la personne et
par conséquent, on peut l'interdire au
nom de la possibilité d'identification
de la personne. Euh alors,
en France ou en Iran ? en France, parce
que en Iran, si on a le voile intégral,
en un sens, il y a aucun problème et
même vous recevrez vraisemblablement les
éloges du pouvoir. Et donc
c'est le problème, je veux dire, du
genre qui intervient à ce niveau-là avec
en intersection avec le religieux.
C'està-dire en Iran, par exemple, je
vous donne cet exemple,
le rejet du voile
est concomitant à ce qu'on pourrait
appeler le rejet d'une culture de deuil,
de tristesse,
de refus, de la joie. Bref, il y a euh
il y a comme une idée de joie de vivre
qui est derrière. D'ailleurs, la plupart
des femmes et des hommes qui en Iran euh
ont participé à ce mouvement, euh on les
voyait sur internet, sur la toile,
danser, chanter ensemble, euh mettre en
cause cette espèce de ségrégation qui
leur paraît insupportable du fait même
de leur sécularisation. Bref, on est
dans ce qu'on pourrait appeler un
domaine où euh la lutte contre le
pouvoir a une dimension politique, à
savoir [raclement de gorge]
un pouvoir ultra autoritaire, voire
totalitaire, mais aussi une dimension
religieuse. Je veux moi-même être maître
et maîtresse de mon choix religieux et
personne ne doit me l'imposer au nom
d'un sacré transcendant, d'un sacré
théocratique. C'est ça cette dimension.
Nous en France, qu'est-ce qu'il faut
qu'on fasse ? Parce que quand on voit
quand l'islam politique est
revendicatif,
juste une juste une remarque sur le cas
de la France quand même. La France est
le pays qui a la plus grosse communauté
juive, la plus grosse communauté
arménienne, la plus grosse communauté
musulmane, la plus grosse communauté
chinoise, la plus grosse communauté
vietnamienne des pays de l'Union
européenne.
La revendication identitaire ne concerne
qu'une partie de la communauté
musulmane. Donc déjà, il faut pas
renverser la charge de la preuve. Le
processus d'intégration fonctionne
simplement. Il y a une part de musulmans
qui ne veulent pas, qui sont sur une
posture séparatiste. C'est ça qui est
assez intéressant. Posture séparatiste
puisqu'ils vont demander qu'on
reconnaisse des spécificités de l'islam
à intégrer dans les pratiques citoyennes
qui peuvent être le la nécessité du
jeûne, le Ramadan, la rupture et cetera.
Enfin bref, tout ça.
Imagine une minute qu'on ait une
majorité d'Hindou qui viennent immigrer
en France. Mais un dou nord ou un nou du
sud,
peu importe, mais qui demande ce qui se
passe en Inde, c'est-à-dire que les
vaches puissent circuler librement dans
les rues puisque'après tout c'est une un
animal sacré.
Est-ce que tu t'es jamais baladé en
Corse ?
Est-ce que Ah non, mais attends attends,
j'en termine parce que si tu veux
l'histoire de la des vaches passent se
maladant librement, il y a eu des cas où
justement des vaches ont rentré dans des
mosquées et à partir de ce moment-là, il
y a eu un massacre, des émeutes et
cetera et cetera. Donc imagine qu'en
France on ait des usando qui disent
"Mais nous notre spécificité c'est que
les femmes, les vaches puissent circuler
librement." Bon est-ce que tu crois que
les musulmans français l'accepteraiit ?
Non. C'est-à-dire que tu vois, on en
arrive à finalement à considérer que la
revendication du séparatisme musulman
est légitime et doit être pris en compte
alors qu'au comme les autres
acceptent encore s'ils acceptent.
Ils acceptent quoi ?
Les vachons liberté.
Oui. Les cochanons aussi. Mais donc tu
vois si tu peux pas le faire reconnaître
par les musulmans. Donc tu vois ne
prends pas d'exemples qui soi pervers.
La question c'est que on en est arrivé à
une posture qui a justifié la loi que
vient d'adopter le gouvernement,
c'est-à-dire la loi contre le
séparatisme parce que ça consisterait à
dire il y a une partie de la communauté
qui doit avoir ses règles à elle qui ne
sont pas qui sont opposables à celles de
la République. Donc tu vois que si tu
tout à coup tu transfères et que tu
prends un autre exemple de minorité
religieuse, tu dirais ça va, on est en
train de délirer complètement. et les
musulmans seraient probablement les
premiers à s'opposer à ce que on
reconnaisse la spécificité de
l'hindouisme. Donc tu vois, on est sur
des sujets sur lesquels il faut bien se
rendre compte que c'est que c'est une
posture aujourd'hui cette ce radicalisme
musulman.
Non, moi je enfin j'ai légèrement un
point de vue différent. Je crois que
pour ce qui est du voile, on parle du
voile, on ne parle pas des vaches.
La ressemblance est quand même assez
lointaine, même si on peut faire des
comparaisons.
Tu vois que le problème est de savoir si
un individu a le libre choix de porter
ou ne pas porter le voile
qui ne s'oppose pas à la pratique
républicaine.
Oui, mais républicaine. Quand tu dis du
côté iranien, on dit islamique.
théocratique. Donc en fait, on peut dire
que les deux sont pas très éloignés sur
le plan idéologique. Républicaine, ça
dépend dans quel sens on le prend.
Mais justement, la République s'est
construite sur la laïcité, c'est-à-dire
qu'on a pu arrêter les gardes de
religion le jour où on a adopté la
laïcité. Donc
laisse terminer pha.
Alors moi je pense que la laïcité
n'a pas un seul sens. Jean Beaufr a on a
distingué 7
qui est quand même l'un des historiens
qui a les plus travaillés sur la
laïcité. Il y a une laïcité qui consiste
à dire l'État est laïque et c'était à
l'origine de la notion de la laïcité.
Or maintenant on en vient à dire c'est
la société qui est laïque.
Le problème c'est qu'il y a un transfert
de l'État à la société. que par exemple
une femme qui porte le voile ne soit pas
enseignante, ça on peut le justifier,
dire l'État est laïque, tu n'as pas le
droit de porter le voile euh quand tu es
enseignante dans un lycée ou dans une
école. Mais le fait de porter le voile
rentrer est-ce que tu as le droit de
rentrer dans une préfecture voilée ?
Mais là euh c'est-à-dire en tant
qu'individu,
ça se discute. Mais le problème, je
crois que c'est
Tu as le droit de faire une sortie
scolaire voilée
de faire pardon
une sortie scolaire voilée.
Une sortie
scolaire voilée accompagné une sortie
scolaire. condition des par
le problème le problème de l'école du
moins [raclement de gorge] pour les
fondateurs de la République n'était pas
les élèves, c'était les enseignants.
C'est pas la même chose. On peut
l'étendre mais alors on pourra dire que
cette notion de laïcité on l'étend à la
société civile.
Par conséquent, moi je crois que il
faudrait trouver des compromis
raisonnables
et [grognement] ne pas parler de
communauté musulmane. Parce que quand on
parle de communauté musulmane, ça veut
dire qu'il forme il forment un groupe
très soudé. Ce n'est pas vrai. On le
voit bien qu'il y a pas il n'y a pas un
vote musulman en France.
Si un vote musulman en France.
Non, il y a pas un vote unifié musulman
en France. Que les musulmans aillent
voté, oui, mais pas unifié.
Par conséquent, moi je crois que pour ce
qui est [raclement de gorge] de l'État
laïque, il faut que les musulmans
respecte cet état laïque.
C'est-à-dire que le voile quand on est
par exemple, je sais pas moi, un préfet
ou une préfète, on n'a pas le droit de
porter le voile tout simplement parce
que vous avez vous assumez une fonction
une fonction euh étatique. Mais en tant
qu'individu,
vous devrez avoir la liberté de porter
ou de ne pas porter. Parce que ce
raisonnement qui consiste à dire euh il
faut respecter la République, la
République islamique en Iran dit il faut
respecter la République islamique. Euh
et par conséquent, c'est le même type,
même si en France, on est dans une
démocratie et en Iran, on est dans une
théocratie antidémocratique.
Le problème essentiel, c'est de voir
dans chaque femme qui porte le voile un
individu ou une individu,
sauf si cette femme se comporte de
manière fondamentaliste, par exemple, en
disant il faut imposer le voile aux
musulmanes et cetera. Et quand quand
quand il y a il y a par exemple
récemment euh je demande à me faire fa
checker, je crois que c'était vers
Bordeaux ou par là, il y a un musulman
très pratiquant qui a suriné euh euh des
musulmans qui étaient pas pratiquants,
qui étaient en train de boire un godet
devant la Gironde ou un truc comme ça.
La culture du Ramadan. C'était pendant
le Ramadan.
Oui, mais il faut il faut le poursuivre
légalement. Mais aucun musulman n'a le
droit d'imposer son point de vue à un
autre musulman, que ce soit en France ou
que ce soit dans un pays musulman. Moi,
mon attitude est que le voile, par
exemple, pour en revenir à ce phénomène
est un phénomène individuel. Une femme a
le droit de porter le voile mais n'a pas
le droit de l'imposer aux autres femmes.
C'est aux autres femmes de décider
souverainement du port ou du non port du
voile. De même, un musulman n'a pas le
droit d'imposer à d'autres musulmans une
conduite que eux ils n'acceptent pas. En
France, on sait bien qu'une partie
relativement importante des musulmans
sont sécularisés. Euh, on pense que les
fondamentalistes, entre guillemets,
enfin c'est une expression qui quand
même prête à beaucoup de confusion. euh
forme aux alentours de entre 20 et 30 %.
Un peu en Europe, un peu partout en
Europe. Donc il y a 70 % qui ne sont pas
euh religieux au sens communautaire du
terme.
Il y a combien de musulmans en Europe ?
En Europe, il y a aux alentours, enfin
les chiffres ne sont pas très exacts,
mais disons que il y a entre 15 et 20
millions.
Et 30 % de 20 millions, c'est combien ?
euh 30 % de 20 millions, ça fait euh ça
fait euh
6 millions,
ça fait 6 millions.
Donc donc il est on dit on dit encore
une fois d'abord 20 millions c'est le
maximum, mettons 15 à 20 millions et
puis euh encore une fois la grande
majorité est quand même pas
fondamentaliste.
Ils sont très très tolérants. Donc en un
sens, moi je suis partisan euh qu'on
traite d'individus, d'ailleurs c'est
républicain euh les les personnes qui
veulent porter ou non le voile et que
[raclement de gorge]
si il n'y a pas de signe
d'adhésion à une vision intolérante de
l'islam qui consiste à vouloir imposer
aux autres musulmans ou aux autres
musulmanes son point de vue, ou ou au
coufar
ou au coufar. Mais bien sûr, la notion
même de coufar est à rejeter au nom du
droit.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire coufar pour
ceux qui s'appoufar ? C'est les
hérétiques, c'est les infidèles. Enfin,
couffar c'est le c'est le pluriel de
kafer. Cafer, ça veut dire infidèle,
hérétique et cetera. Mais cette notion
ailleurs n'a aucune place dans une
société démocratique. D'ailleurs, c'est
ce qu'on demande en Iran. Vous n'avez
pas le droit de dire que un tel est
croyant ou incroyant. La notion même de
de dater en un sens pose problème parce
que c'est une notion théologiquement
connoté de manière péjorative et par
conséquent moi je pense qu'il faut qu'il
y ait une sorte de tolérance froide
vis-à-vis du voile
dans le sens où est un phénomène
strictement individuel qu'il ne que
qu'une femme voilée ne veut pas
l'imposer aux autres et surtout que ce
cette espèce de voile ne doit pas aller
au-delà d'un certain seuil. Encore une
fois, le voile intégral pose un problème
de sécurité publique. Donc, il faut
l'interdire.
Pierre, j'aimerais avant que tu rebondis
sur Farad, j'aimerais qu'on aborde le
conflit israopalestinien. Est-ce qu'il y
a des fous de dieu là-dedans à gauche, à
droite ? Comment ça se passe ? Quelles
vont être les répercussions ? Quelles
vont être les montées en terme de
terrorisme à gauche, à droite ? Comment
ça se passe ? Écoute sur le sur je
reviens une minute sur ce que disait
Farad parce que disc poser le problème
autour du che voile si tu veux est une
manière à mon avis trop ambigue de poser
la question. Tu vois aujourd'hui
justement à propos de Gaza qu'une grande
partie de ce qu'on croit est une espèce
de coexistence que la laïcité permet
permett. La laïcité est un système
proprement français qui a assez mal
compris ailleurs. Assez mal. Par
exemple, si tu vas aux États-Unis, la
laïcité, il savent pas ce que c'est.
C'est une société multi culturelle et
cetera. En Angleterre, c'est pareil.
Pense quand même que le plus vieux
conflit religieux en Europe, c'est le
conflit irlandais, c'est-à-dire les
anglicans contre les catholiques. Et que
celui-là, il s'est jamais arrêté. Bon,
donc tu vois, tu as des identités comme
celle-là et la laïcité était une espèce
de garantie que la 3e République a
imposé justement pour en terminer avec
le avec les guerres de religion. C'est
quand ça a quand même été un siècle et
demi parce que nous,
on avait aussi des câaux radicalisés,
c'est ça ?
Pardon ?
Nous aussi, on avait des câaux
radicalisés. Ah bah oui bien sûr.
C'était les guerres de religion c'était
assez effrayant puisque si tu veux
c'était le massacre du voisin quoi. Si
tu avais un voisin protestant il va
mieux que ce soit toi qui le tue avant
que ce soit lui qui tue. Tu vois c'était
le princip
c'est pas une guerre économique
là-dessous sous ces prétextes de
religion de machin.
Non ça c'est plutôt contre les juifs
l'idée.
Il y a une dimension mais la vraie
raison est quand même catholique versus.
C'est ça qu'on a eu du mal à comprendre,
c'est que la religion pouvait être un
véritable facteur politique et qu'il
fallait pas aller chercher derrière un
critère économique, sociologique et
cetera. Non, c'est c'est ce que écrit
Bern Bom dans son bouquin, ce qui
s'appelle le un silence religieux qui
analyse la posture de la gauche face à
la révolution iranienne. Il dis, on
comprenait pas, on ne comprenait pas ce
qui se passait. Et donc on a on s'est
dit il y a pas de problème, ça va se ça
va se régler par lui-même. Or, on
s'aperçoit aujourd'hui à travers le cas
iranien. Alors moi j'ai une remarque à
faire si tu veux parce que encore une
fois pour l'Iran est un pays assez
spécifique parce que c'est du chisme.
Dans le chisme, il y a une hiérarchie
religieuse. C'est-à-dire que tu peux pas
non plus dériver complètement parce
c'est comme dans le le christianisme. Tu
as au-dessus de toi si tu veux une
hiérarchie qui est celle de la papauté
et donc tu ne peux pas avoir une
adaptation libre si tu dans le
protestant
adaptation libre des textes religieux.
Oui oui c'est ça. Mais par contre dans
le protestantisme et Luther c'était
exactement ça. C'était dénié au pape le
droit de de d'interpréter les textes
religieux. Donc le protestantisme qui va
naître est un protestantisme de la libre
interprétation où il y a pas d'hérarchie
religieuse où à la limite chacun peut
créer son église. C'est ce qui se passe
aux États-Unis si tu veux. Et
effectivement c'est la base même du ce
qui empêche pas les protestants de se
battre entre eux. C'est-à-dire que les
pères fondateurs qui partent aux
États-Unis sont des protestants
persécutés par les anglicans, par les
autres protestants et cetera. Donc on
est sur des sujets qui sont
sociologiquement difficiles à comprendre
parce que notre laïcité à nous et il
faut y tenir est difficilement
compréhensible pour les autres. Donc sur
le fond, on s'aperçoit bien que pourquoi
je disais ça sur la la à propos du
voile, c'est qu'on s'aperçoit bien
aujourd'hui à propos du conflit à Gaza
que tu vas avoir un type qui va décider
de tuer le voisin ou de violer une fille
parce que elle est c ou elle est ça. Ça
peut être une fille juive par des
musulmans, ça peut être une famille une
fille musulmane par des juifs. Mais
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui
horrible, c'est horrible,
c'est absolument effroyable.
C'est-à-dire que la fracture se crée à
l'intérieur de du système français. Et
c'est moi, c'est ce que je craignais le
plus, c'est-à-dire la transposition
intellectuelle de ce qui se passe à Gaza
avec toutes les caractéristiques, on y
reviendra si tu veux, le de les
transposer en France. Or, on voit bien
qu'il y avait des torts des deux côtés,
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a deux radicales
face- à face. Il y a le Hamas d'un côté,
il y a Netaniaou de l'autre. Donc, tu
vas te dire pourquoi tu dois prendre
position.
C'est pas que Netaniaou, il est pas tout
seul.
Non, non, non. Bien sûr, bien sûr, bien
sûr. Mais par exemple, pour te dire
l'importance de la communication sur un
sujet comme ça, le phénomène de la
colonisation sauvage des juifs radicaux
en 6 Jordanie existe maintenant depuis
plusieurs années. Elle se traduit par le
fait de création de colonies sauvages
sur le territoire relevant de l'autorité
palestinienne, protégé par l'armée, par
Talhal avec des routes réservées à
Tshal. Tu vois ce que ça veut dire ? Une
recolonisation. Mais tu remarques que
depuis Gaza, on parle plus de ça.
Attends, j'ai pas entendu des routes
réservées à l'armée pour pouvoir
sécuriser les colonies sauvages.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a une position
totalement illégale contraire du haro
international. Mais tu vois qu'avec le
massacre à Gaza tout à coup, on parle
plus on ne parle pas de la 6 jordanie.
Or, en si Jordanie, il y a justement ça,
c'est-à-dire qu'à chaque fois qu'il y a
un colon qui va tuer un palestinien ou
un palestinien qui va tuer un colon, on
est exactement dans une dans le système
de crispation qui va permettre parce que
l'armée est là, parce que il y a des
armes partout et cetera, de rallumer si
tu veux le conflit. Donc quand je dis
qu'il y a deux radicalismes face- à
face, c'est que tu as Netahuou et les
juifs radicaux et tu as effectivement le
Hamas. Il y a aujourd'hui des colons, tu
sais qu'une des conditions de la paix
était justement que les colons de
Israéliens de Gaza évacuent. Donc ils
ont été évacués. Maintenant, il demande
à revenir à Gaza.
Donc, on est en train de préparer le
match suivant. Quoi ?
Farad, quel regard vous portez sur le
conflit isra-palestinien le 7 octobre,
avant le 7 octobre, après le 7 octobre
et quelle répercussion ça va avoir ? Je
crois que le 7 octobre, il s'agit d'un
crime. Il faut le reconnaître.
Quel que soit
l'étendue de l'hégémonie et de la
répression israélienne contre les
Palestiniens,
tuer 1200 individus ne se justifie ni
moralement ni légalement. Bon, donc
pauvre gamin qui était un concert.
Exactement.
Donc donc la condamnation sans rappel de
ce crime.
[raclement de gorge]
Est-ce que cela justifie qu'il y ait
presque 40000
Palestin Gazaouis tué par l'armée
israélienne et souvent de manière
vraiment insupportable où enfants,
femmes, vieux et tout ça ont été
vraiment massacrés sans qu'ils aient
participé à au côté [raclement de gorge]
militaire de Hamas. Ça, je crois que
c'est vraiment euh inacceptable. Et
d'ailleurs, moi ce que ce qui
m'intéresse et ce que je déplore, c'est
de voir comment dans les médias de
l'autre côté, médias iranien arabe et
cetera, on voit c phénomène. Je prends
deux
[raclement de gorge] deux événements
fondamentaux euh qui actuellement ont un
on a un impact important en Europe.
l'Ukraine, l'invasion de l'Ukraine par
la Russie et [raclement de gorge] cette
guerre
d'Israël contre Masse. Bon, de mon point
de vue qui est contestable comme tout
point de vue individuel,
je crois que Ukraine doit se défendre
contre cette invasion russe, même si il
y a énormément de problèmes derrière.
Euh il y a une légitimité, même si
encore une fois on peut dire que les
Russes ont aussi un argumentaire et
cetera de de l'Ukraine
[raclement de gorge] dont l'intégrité
territoriale euh doit être euh garantie
euh internationalement. Bon
ah c'est un peu foutu là.
Voilà mais regardons ce qui se passe du
côté palestinien
dans le monde musulman, l'opinion
publique, pas les gouvernements qui sont
corrompus et qui sont souvent
procidentaux. Il y a deux gouvernements
qui ont protesté, c'est le gouvernement
iranien et le turc enfin
essentiellement. Et il y a les aussi
mais aussi n'est pas ne sont pas un
gouvernement au sens ne sont pas un
gouvernement.
Il y a l'Afrique du Sud aussi mais c'est
pas de la région.
Oui mais bon on sait très bien que même
la Turquie n'a rien fait. Je veux dire
[raclement de gorge]
effectivement
façade.
Oui. Voilà. De même, la France a
condamné un certain nombre de choses,
l'Angleterre, l'Allemagne beaucoup moins
parce que il y a cette espèce de
sentiment de culpabilité vis-à-vis
d'Israël. Mais dans les faits, on a rien
fait contre ce phénomène. Dès que l'Iran
fait quelque chose,
il y a des condamnations et puis il y a
des des mesures de restriction
économique ou autres.
J'ouvre une parenthèse, les Iraniens,
ils sont pas tout blancs dans cette
histoire. Mais bien sûr que non, c'est
la société civile iranienne qui pâtit
alors que les tenants du pouvoir ont
leurs sources et une grande partie du
pétrole qui est vendu va dans leur poche
et par conséquent ça affaiblit la
société civile irenienne, les classes
moyennes irenniennes et leur capacité de
contestation. Ça exactement le contraire
à mon avis de de de l'effet escompté par
ces mesures de restriction. Alors pour
un musulman, euh le fait que l'Occident
euh soutienne l'Ukraine sous cette forme
devient suspecte parce que il voit
comment l'Occident soutient Israël de
manière inconditionnelle. Les États-Unis
ont beau dénoncé un certain nombre de
choses, mais il y a quand même euh, je
crois 23 milliards de dollars d'aide
militaire et autres euh des États-Unis
dont une partie euh pour euh le
financement euh euh de l'aide euh aux
Palestiniens pour ce qui est de l'aide
alimentaire ou médicamente, mais bref,
on est quand même dans cette espèce de
double poids, double mesure qui
disquadite l'Occident.
Euh je veux dire comment voulez-vous
qu'un musulman croit à la légitimité de
ce qui se passe en Ukraine, la défense
de l'Ukraine contre la Russie alors que
il voit de manière extrêmement claire
cette espèce de dissymétrie dans la
manière dont cet Occident traite
Israël et la question palestinienne. Et
donc ça discrédite cet Occident qui se
veut en quelque sorte juge moral du
monde. Et moi je pense que c'est par la
suite qu'on verra les répercussions de
ce phénomène là. Quand il y aura des
formes de rébellion, de djihadisme ou
autres, on ne comprendra pas que
l'arrière-plan était ces phénomènes là
d'humiliation. Et donc ça la notion
d'humiliation
intervient activement dans cette façon
dont certains groupes minoritaires de
musulmans peuvent réagir contre
l'hégémonie occidentale.
Pierre, avant de te redonner la parole
et que tu nous montres tes belles
jambes,
Fara Farade, pardon, les sanctions,
est-ce que ça marche ? Les sanctions sur
l'Iran, est-ce que ça marche ? Mais
Pierre est mieux placé que moi pour en
parler mais et on n'a pas un seul cas
hm hm
de sanction qui est marché
l'Afrique du Sud quand même un peu, non
?
Hm.
L'Afrique du Sud
l'Afrique du Sud c'est pas ça. C'est il
y a une dynamique intérieure de la
société et puis le fait que euh les
dirigeants de la partide ont pris
conscience
de la de l'illégitimité et de
l'impossibilité de continuer cette
affaire. Ce n'est pas du tout les
sanctions qui ont été à l'origine de
cette
est-ce que les sanctions sur l'Iran
ont renforcé
les gens en place
que les sanctions renfor les sanctions
renforcent toujours le régime en place.
Est-ce que ça fait
parce que c'est lui qui gère les flux.
Est-ce qu' Est-ce que ça fait comme en
Russie ? Plus la Russie est sanctionnée,
plus les Russes font bloc derrière.
Est-ce que en Iran c'est pareil sens ?
mon sens, les sanctions
frappent d'abord la société civile et ne
frappe pas les les les détenteurs du
pouvoir
et c'est fait pour ça que pour que la
société civile se rebelle et se révolte.
Or, la société civile, je veux dire en
dessail de pauvreté et d'indigence,
souvent n'a plus la capacité de se
rebeller parce que pour cela, il faut
qu'il y ait un niveau décent qui assure
en quelque sorte la vie quotidienne.
Je ne pense pas que les sanctions ai
renforcé le pouvoir iranien.
Ils l'ont en un sens, ils ont montré au
grand jour son illégitimité dans la
manière dont il réparti les ressources.
Mais c'est un pouvoir qui ne montre
jusqu'à présent du moins aucun signe de
défaillance. La répression contre le
mouvement le dernier mouvement social en
Iran le montre. De même en Syrie, une
grande partie de la société civile était
et est contre Bachar Alassad mais le
pouvoir sanguinaire demeure là. Donc les
sanctions, moi je ne crois pas à leur
efficacité
au niveau de du [raclement de gorge]
pouvoir euh
pour déstabiliser le régime. C'est ça.
Pour
les régimes ne seront pas renversés par
les sanctions. Ça le [grognement] rend
plus sanguinaire, ça rend plus cruel et
ça fait souffrir davantage la société
civile.
Pierre, tu rebondis ?
Non, je crois que Farad a tout dit.
C'est-à-dire que les sanctions sont une
espèce de gestion théorique euh qui
devrait permettre à un pays de que
devrait permettre de faire pression pour
un pays qui qui renoncerait à son
système. Le cas de l'Afrique du Sud est
intéressant parce que justement
il y a un homme exceptionnel dans le
paysage he qui est Nelson Mandela.
C'estàd le type qui va non seulement
arriver au pouvoir mais qui va justement
refuser d'expulser les colons.
Hm hm.
C'est le seul cas d'Afrique si tu veux
dans lequel la le rétablissement d'une
voie républicaine ne s'est pas traduite
par l'expulsion des colons. Or, c'est le
seul pays qui aujourd'hui a un taux de
croissance en Afrique. C'est
extraordinaire. C'est-à-dire celui qui
en a pas d'autres.
Pardon ?
Tu es sûr qu'il y en a pas d'autres en
croissance ? Bah écoute, faut les
chercher en tout cas parce que celui-là
effectivement alors c'est ça qui lui
donne sa légitimité pour saisir la Cour
internationale de justice justement pour
dire "Mais pour Israël,
il y a un massacre qui est en cours."
Et évidemment quand c'est l'Afrique du
Sud qui s'exprime, ça n'a pas du tout le
même sens que quand c'est la France,
l'Angleterre ou les États-Unis
puisque [raclement de gorge] là on est
effectivement dans cette apparition de
ce de ces bricks si tu veux qui
aujourd'hui ont une légitimité que nous
avons perdu. C'est-à-dire tout ce que
tout ce que disait euh Farad. Euh
rappelle-toi des épisodes
extraordinaires. 11 septembre 15
saoudien sur 19. George Bouche en
janvier 2002 fait les pays de l'Ax du
Mâ. Les pays de l'Ax du M, c'est l'Iran,
l'Irak et la Corée du Nord. Il y avait
nianien, niakien, ni nord-éen dans les
avions. Donc, tu as là la un exemple de
fabrication de l'ennemi appuyé
effectivement par les néoconservateurs
américains qui va déclencher une guerre
en Afghanistan. D'abord, rappelle-toi
que les Afghans, ils disaient Benaden,
nous on veut pas vous le livrer mais on
peut le mettre dans un pays tiers. Non,
ils ont dit donnez-nous les preuves que
c'est lui et on vous livrera.
Oui, enfin quelque chose comme ça. Mais
en tout cas, il fallait une guerre parce
que les États-Unis n'a jamais n'ont
jamais connu la guerre depuis la guerre
de sécession. Le dernier combattant de
la guerre de sécession est mort en 55.
Donc, ils ne savent pas ce que c'est
qu'une ville détruite, que c'est qu'une
privation, que c'est d'étéquet de
rationnement. Il fallait une vengeance
après l'11 de septembre. Donc les
néoconservateurs et les néovangéliques
américains concoquent cette nouvelle
politique, la guerre globale contre le
terrorisme. Mais le terrorisme c'est un
moyen d'action, c'est pas un ennemi. La
meilleure preuve c'est que quand lesour
font des attentats sur la plastienne
anmain on dit oui mais là c'est pas
pareil. C'est des attentats de
résistance c'est pas des vrais
terroristes. Tu vois ce que je veux dire
? Donc la guerre globale contre le
terrorisme, au lieu de la refuser nous
pays européens qui savons ce que c'est
que le terrorisme, on sait on s'est tous
aligné sur ce qu'on fait les Américains.
Deuxième remarque, pour aller justifier
la guerre à l'Irak, parce que encore une
fois, c'était difficile de trouver des
preuves, il y a cette espèce de
comédiené avec Coline Powell exposant
que là, il a les preuves dans sa petite
fiole que il y a des armes de
destruction massive en Irak. Tu te rends
compte ? S'il avait laissé tomber la
fiole, on aurait su soit la moitié de
l'assemblée générale de l'ONU mouré,
soit on prouvé qu'il y avait rien.
Alors, je me suis beaucoup interrogé par
il y en a qui auraient sorti des pailles
peut-être
des quoi des
des pailles.
Écoute, en tout cas moi je me suis posé
la question parce que pour arriver à
convaincre un type qui Coline Powell qui
avait le prestige de la guerre du golf,
le général et cetera, les Américains
aiment beaucoup ce genre de profil.
Pour arriver à le convaincre, qu'il
fallait qu'il fasse cette démonstration
mensongère devant l'ONU. Il fallait que
ça vienne de son entourage. Il fallait
que ce soit un type qui ait sa
confiance. Tu as regardé les métadonnées
du document du document qu'ils lui ont
donné à Coline Powell,
pardon.
Tu as regardé elle qui avait construit
ce fichier ? Non mais ce qui ce qui me
paraît intéressant justement, c'est que
Coline Poell était le grand concurrent
de George Bouche dans le parti
républicain. C'est-à-dire le seul moyen
de le décrédibilité, c'était de le faire
mettre si tu veux dans cette scène
idiote où on savait qu'il était en train
de mentir puisque la IEA là le les tous
les organismes internationaux disaient
"C'est fini, il y a plus rien." Bon et
donc tu sais que finalement il va
disparaître puisque quand ça sera révélé
après l'invasion mais c'est au bout de
tout ça vous tu as une aviasion tu as
plus de 100000 personnes qui sont tué tu
vas avoir l'explosion d'un pays qui
s'appelle l'Irak et aujourd'hui l'Irak
n'a toujours pas été reconstitué
et ça iradie un peu partout dans la zone
et ça irradie un peu partout et ça va
donner naissance justement à Daesh et à
tout ce qu'on connaît
exactement
donc finalement tu te dis mais quand
est-ce qu'on fait le procès de ce genre
de processus ? J'ai j'ai une question,
je fais j'ouvre une parenthèse. Euh
Farade, est-ce que vous avez entendu un
général américain qui s'appelle Wesley
Clark
et qui a de nombreuses années a dit euh
"J'ai été me balader au Pentagone,
c'était juste après les attentats du 11
septembre. J'ai été me balader au
Pentagone, j'avais un copain à voir.
J'ai un autre collègue qui me dit
"Venez, venez mon général, vous allez
pas croire vos oreilles. J'ai la
stratégie pour les prochaines années. On
va faire tomber 7 pays
en 5 ans". Et il termine par l'Iran.
Comment les Iraniens perçoivent les
Américains quand il y a ce type de
déclaration d'un général américain qui a
quand même quatre étoiles, qui a été
commandant des forenses américaines en
Europe, de l'OTAN, pardon,
et qui fait ce type de déclaration, ça
sert à la propagande iranienne, c'est la
strictalité. Les Iraniens sont quand
même, malgré être sous le jou de gens un
peu tendus, sont quand même pas dupe
de de la duplicité de la de la fourberie
de la politique extérieure américaine où
ils se disent "L'Américains, c'est quand
même super sympa. Il y a le McDonald's,
il y a Burger King, c'est super cool
en ce enfin ça dépend du moment.
C'estàdire en ce moment et comme il y a
une opposition profonde contre le
pouvoir en place, contre la théocratie,
tout ce qui contredit cette théocratie
est aveuglément
en un sens approuvé.
C'estàd que si je veux déstabiliser
l'Iran,
c'està-dire déstabiliser l'Iran, d'abord
on a le sentiment que le pouvoir
américain
n'a pas la capacité de le faire sans
trop de dégâts.
Pour qui ? Pour les Iraniens ou pour les
Américains ? pour les Américains
eux-mêmes. Je veux dire, s'ils veulent
déstabiliser l'Iran au sens d'une
intervention militaire, euh ça coûte
beaucoup plus cher que l'Irak. Déjà, on
voit bien la le désastre iraakien. Euh
c'est vraiment euh l'invasion de l'Irak
qui a été à l'origine, comme disait
Pierre euh de Daesh. C'est le l'élite
politique de Daesh s'est constituée dans
les prisons iraakiennes gérées par des
Américains.
Alors tout le problème est que
[raclement de gorge] euh les Américains
avec Biden ne veulent pas de guerre avec
l'Iran. Ben c'est bien,
c'est bien. Mais le problème essentiel
c'est que tout en ne voulant pas de
guerre avec l'Iran, il y a leur relation
avec Israël. Israël voudrait une guerre
avec l'Iran. Mais parce que
vous êtes sûr de ça ? Vous êtes sûr que
Israël veut réellement une guerre avec
l'Iran ? Et est-ce que
Non, je ne suis pas à 100 % sûr, mais
disons que Netaniaou
a besoin politiquement d'une guerre.
pense que l'Iran, c'est un peu la menace
existentielle contre Israël. C'est le
seul pays
à tort ou à raison ?
Non, à tort ou à raison. Je crois qu'en
partie à tort en partie a raison. De
même que du côté iranien, on pense
qu'Israël est une plie au Moyen-Orient
à tort et à raison. À tortur et à
raison. Mais en même temps, Israël est
un pays qui est reconnu
internationalement, qui est aux Nations
Unies et cetera. et donc vouloir euh en
un sens [raclement de gorge] euh mettre
fin à l'existence de l'État d'Israël,
euh c'est contraire euh aux lois
internationales et puis finalement à un
état de fête qui me paraît en un sens
incontournable. Et puis le fait que
l'Iran veuille [raclement de gorge]
mettre fin à l'existence d'Israël est
l'extrême droite israélienne qui joue
sur ce problème pour justifier en
quelque sorte sa violence dans la
région. Est-ce que vous trouvez pas que
la population israélienne, la population
iranienne sont coincés
l'un comme l'autre avec des fous furieux
radicalisés qui sont une minorité
et le fait qu'on les sanctionne, le fait
qu'on leur tape dessus tout le temps en
fait ça empêche la population civile de
se séparer de
Je crois que c'est c'est un état de fête
et je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
vous. C'est-à-dire que l'écrasante
majorité des Iraniens actuellement euh
[raclement de gorge]
ne se reconnaissent pas dans cet état
théocratique, mais en même temps euh ils
n'ont pas d'organisation, ils n'ont pas
de leadership et tout cela parce que il
y a une répression massive. Mais en même
temps, la solution ne serait pas
l'invasion de l'Iran parce que ça créé
ça créerait une situation à l'irakienne.
Je veux dire, ces invasions ne
donneraient pas de résultat
satisfaisants euh et seraiit à l'origine
des formes de radicalisation qu'il est
très difficile de prévoir d'avance.
C'est vraiment une
l'Iran ça fait quand même plusieurs fois
la superficie de l'Irak. Ça fait 1600000
km². Ça fait plus de trois fois la
superficie de la France et donc c'est
pas n'importe pay magnifique.
Donc ça si par exemple il y a une
invasion de l'Iran, il va y avoir un
branle bas dans la région. Les pays du
golfe seront atteints. Une grande partie
de la sécurité de de
[raclement de gorge] du pétrole pour
l'Europarbur
vont être fermé.
Oui, on aurait on aurait vraiment une
situation explosive dans cette région et
donc après comment gérer cette situation
et moi j'ai l'impression que les
États-Unis actuellement
ne veulent plus se concentrer sur le
Moyen-Orient parce que c'est la Chine et
la Russie qui sont les centres de mire
actuellement. Euh encore une fois, moi
je ne crois pas à des solutions
militaires occidentales contre des pays
comme l'Iran ou comme d'autres.
J'ai pas compris les centres de MIR.
Vous faites une blague en russe ou vous
faites une blague euh J'ai pas compris
le
le centre de visé enfin les les les amis
principaux. Mir en russe ça veut dire
paix. Non, le côté russe et le côté
chinois sont les deux menaces majeures
du point de vue américain. Et et donc le
Moyen-Orient n'a plus cette importance
capitale qu'il avait, ne serait-ce que
parce que maintenant les États-Unis au
niveau de la production du pétrole sont
autosuffisants, contrairement à l'Europe
qui est dépendant de la région et par
conséquent moi je ne crois pas à cette
solution militaire
sur les pays autoritaires ou même
totalitaire de la région au nom d'une
moralité supérieure qu'incarnerait
l'Occident. L'Occident n'incarne pas
cette moralité supérieure.
Plus n'incarne plus. jamais incarné si
ce n'est par le pouvoir. Je veux dire
même au 19e siècle avec les les colon la
colonisation et cetera, bon ce n'était
quand même pas un pouvoir légitime au
sens fort du terme mais peu importe il
n'y a pas de légitimité occidentale
aujourd'hui au niveau international qui
lui donnerait le droit d'intervenir
militairement dans un certain nombre de
pays. D'ailleurs, on l'a vu avec la
catastrophe.
Tiens Farad, donne la parole à Pierre.
[grognement] le je comprends pas dans ta
question
parce que tu crois raisonner sur
l'avocat du diable.
Non non attends je je termine ce que je
veux dire.
[raclement de gorge]
le quand on dit les États-Unis ont
décidé que moi si tu veux j'ai participé
à des instances décisionnelles qui vont
générer la la réflexion stratégique et
qui vont ensuite décider que bon le or
je te le dis je te l'ai décrit à propos
des élites françaises mais c'est pareil
sur les élites américaines euh on on
pense toujours que on a les moyens de la
puissance d'ailleurs elle est reconnue
par les autres et que ces moyens de la
puissance vont permettre de résoudre un
certain nombre moyens militaires vont
permettre de résoudre un certain nombre
de questions. Bon, c'était vrai
également à l'époque de l'URSS et je
vais prendre un exemple qui est très
caractéristique qui est l'Afghanistan.
L'Afghanistan, tu penses bien que le les
anglais s'étaient cassés les dents
l'époque impériale, mais enfin c'est pas
grave, c'était les anglais. Donc tu
imagines que autour de Brenjf en 79, tu
avais certainement des conseillers qui
disaient "Oh monsieur le premier
secrétaire, ne vous inquiétez pas,
l'Afghanistan, on va vous faire ça vite
fait. C'est des c'est rien que des
boules, c'est des mecs qui
pas de mot comme ça ici hein.
Non mais je veux dire, tu vois ce que je
veux dire ? C'était une vision
méprisante des Afghans qui était
évidemment on va vous les faire vite
fait. Bon invasion que tu connais vite
fait effectivement les Russes débarquent
à Kabou et ils prennent la capitale.
Puis ensuite effectivement 10 ans
d'occupation qui vont se terminer par un
départ la queue entre les jambes.
Pourquoi cette pourquoi je je vais
d'abord là-dessus ? Ensuite je
reviendrai sur le la suite duoire.
[raclement de gorge]
Nous étions en pleine époque où l'armée
rouge était une grande mécanique qui
allait déferler dans les plaines
d'Europe centrale avec des milliers de
chars et qui allaient et cetera et
cetera et cetera. Or, on les trouve là
face à des des gens qui sont des
combattants
qui [raclement de gorge] sont tous armés
mais armés avec des petites armes, ils
ont pas grand-chose mais qui fait que
les Russes vont progressivement s'user
s'user s'user. Bon, il y avait un type
qui all à l'époque en Afghanistan, c'est
Olivier Rois et il rentrait en disant
"Mais je comprends pas."
Je peux juste couper une parenthèse. Euh
les Russes qui font la guerre à
l'Ukraine, pourquoi ils les ont pas
aplati à l'américaine dès les de en 48
he ? [soupir]
Tu comprends ce que je veux dire quand
je dis aplati à l'amérique ? Non non non
parce que tu ne tiens pas compte de la
spécificité de chacun des théâtres.
C'est ça qui fait la différence. Quand
tu es dans une position de puissance, on
te dit mais tel théâtre, on a les moyens
de faire si de faire ça. L'Afghanistan,
moi j'y suis allé, c'est une zone de
confin en sens géopolitique,
c'est-à-dire une zone dans laquelle les
toutes les populations qui étaient
persécutées par les empires environnants
sont venus se réfugier dans cette zone
de montagne qui s'appelle l'indouche et
donc chaque vallée est différente de la
valise de la de la vallée à côté. Ça
veut dire tu peux toujours prendre la
capitale, ça pose strictement aucun
problème, tout le monde s'en fout mais
il faut prendre toutes les vallées les
unes derrière les autres. Ça veut dire
c'est une guerre de les Russes 10 ans.
Donc Olivier Roy qui était la seule
personne qui continuait à aller en
Afghanistan disait "Mais on comprend pas
l'armée rouge sort plus de ses bases.
Les types reçoivent pas de comment dire
le soutien logistique, ils reçoivent pas
l'alimentation et cetera." Bref, au bout
de 10 ans, les Russes s'en vont. Alors,
on avait aidé effectivement les on avait
aidé effectivement les résistants
afghans. Mais [raclement de gorge] tu
connais la suite après
pardon
les moujidines ? Non, pas les ming comme
ça.
Ah oui, alors c'est les combattants de
la liberté quand même. Faut l'inventer
celle-là. Et donc après la suite de
l'histoire, tu la connais. Après le 11
septembre, les Américains vont s'y
coller eux aussi. Ils vont dire "Mais
c'est pareil, l'Afghanistan, c'est pas
On va vous faire ça vite fait chef, vous
inquiétez pas." C'est-à-dire que tu as
autour des décideurs l'illusion de la
puissance. Cette illusion de la
puissance a un aspect militaire et a un
aspect idéologique. Notre société est
supérieure à la leure, donc nos moyens
militaires vont permettre de gagner. Les
Américains, il aura fallu 20 ans pour se
rendre compte que l'Afghanistan, comme
on l'appelait, c'est le tombeau des
empires. C'est-à-dire aucun n'a réussi à
le conquérir. Mais tu peux pas.
C'est ta femme. Si c'est ta femme, je te
pardonne. C'est ma femme. [rires]
Tu te rends bien compte sur le cas de la
de l'Afghanistan que c'était exactement
des une somme d'erreurs stratégiques qui
se situe au niveau des décideurs. Bon,
je te prends maintenant l'exemple de
l'Ukraine. L'Ukraine,
[raclement de gorge] le découpage
territorial de l'ancien du RSS, c'était
le camarade Stalin, commissaire aux
nationalités, qui s'en était chargé. Il
avait une idée, c'était évidemment aucun
territoire ne doit être homogène et donc
il doit y avoir des mixes qui doivent
permettre à Moscou de toujours
intervenir le jour nécessaire. Ce qu'il
n'avait pas prévu, c'est qu'un jour la
Fédération exploserait. Bon, on peut
peut pas lui reprocher mais en tout cas
lui, il a eu en tout cas cette
intelligence de se dire on a toujours
les moyens de l'intervention. Donc quand
l'Ukraine se sépare de la de la l'URSS,
tu as une partie de la région est le
Donnet et Donbas qui reste peuplé de
russophone. Or une des premières
révolutions de la révolution de Maidan,
c'est de décider que l'Ukrainien était
la seule langue unique en Ukraine. pas
un texte dans les accords de Minsk après
il y avait pas un texte dans les accords
de Minsk qui disait voilà il faut
peut-être respecter
non les accords de Minsk après c'est les
Français allemand qui essayent
d'empêcher si tu veux que la guerre
n'éclate et qui vont donc essayer de
trouver une solution en faisant
l'intermédiation en disant il faut
respecter et cetera mais entre-temps tu
vois les anciens colons devenus soumis
les anciens colons ont commencé la
guerre c'est-à-dire que au moment où
Poutine décide l'intervention il y avait
déjà eu 14000 morts à la frontière donc
on était dans une situation de conflit
des deux côtés Oui oui, c'est ça des
deux côtés. C'està-dire que les accords
de Minsk étaient une tentative
d'empêcher que cette guerre civile dans
l'intérieur du territoire de l'Ukraine
ne dérive. Bon,
je peux je peux t'arrêter juste une
seconde et quand j'entends Gu Merkel ou
François Hollande dire les accords de
mines, c'était simplement pour gagner du
temps pour que l'Ukraine se réarme.
C'est pip toujours le dire. Remarque
François Hollande, c'est pas l'homme
auquel j'accorderai le plus de crédit
sur des sujets comme cela. Mais enfin en
tout cas effectivement tu un des
problèmes de l'armée rouge justement
c'est que quand le système éclate, il y
a des pays qui gardent une partie de
cette armée, d'autres qui n'en ont
aucune et cetera. Quand par exemple les
Arméniens décident de faire la jonction
avec le haarabac, il y a pas d'armée
azerbaïdjanaise. Donc ils vont rentrer
dans le lart, si tu veux et ils vont
prendre une partie du territoire. Et il
y a c'est quand les Azerbaïdjanes, ils
vont se redoter d'une armée avec les
ressources pétrolières qu'on va jouer le
match retour. Donc tu vois, on est dans
des situations qui sont très très
différentes. Et le cas de l'Ukraine,
pour revenir à celui-là, c'est
effectivement le cas où il y avait pas
d'armée ukrainienne, il en resté des
résidus mais en tout cas il y avait pas
de quoi résister.
Et les Russes n'avaient pas respecté les
accords de Budapest.
Les quels accords de Budapest ?
Bah lesquels sont enquels tuas en tête
? Non, j'ai rien moi comme accord de
D'accord.
Pour
autre question, question internet. Que
devient l'Afghanistan ? On a répondu. On
va revenir un peu sur l'Iron.
Quel conseil tu don vous donneriez à
quelqu'un qui veut aller visiter ce
patrimoine archéologique
extraordinaire, ces paysages
extraordinaires, ces gens
extraordinaires
l'Iront. Est-ce que ça craint d'aller
là-bas ?
Mais c'est qui ces gens ? C'est les
Iraniens ou les Afghans ?
Non, nous. Est-ce que on peut faire du
Tourisme quand visiter cette région
extraordinaire ? Tu parles de
l'Afghanistan ou de l'Iran ?
L'Iran. Bah, l'Afghanistan est
magnifique aussi.
Est-ce que ça craint d'aller en Iran ?
Il y en a qui vont et qui n'ont aucun
problème.
Il y en a qui ne reviennent pas.
Non, il y en a très peu
Il y en a très peu des problèmes mais
que les médias évidemment mettent en
exerge à juste titre à l'incens parce
que on leur dénit en quelque sorte leur
liberté euh en les mettant en prison et
en
les traitant un peu comme une sorte de
monnaie de rançon.
Et par conséquent euh si on veut aller,
il faut bien comprendre que les risques
ne sont pas les mêmes que si on veut
aller par exemple en Allemagne.
Non, la Belgique la Belgique ou les même
les États-Unis, même si aux États-Unis,
on peut avoir quand même quelques ennuis
euh s'il y a un attentat euh
de meurtre, c'est-à-dire par quelqu'un
par un fou qui veut tuer n'importe qui
dans la rue.
Il y a un niveau de risque qui
incontestablement est supérieur à celui
qu'on encourt si on veut aller dans les
pays européen. Mais disons qu'il y en a
qui vont et la grande majorité n'a pas
de problème. Évidemment, ils sont pas
très nombreux ceux qui vont. Est-ce que
les Iraniens quand ils ont vu l'échec
des Américains en Afghanistan, en Irak,
euh est-ce que ça a un peu euh
galvaniser les les Iraniens en se disant
"Bon, les Américains ont débarqué en
Afghanistan pour dégager les Talibans.
20 ans plus tard, qui est-ce qu'il a au
pouvoir Pierre ?
Les Taliban
pour combien de milliards ? [rires]
Ah oui, non mais ça c'est une question
idiote. C'est c'est pour ça que je te
dis l'intérêt c'est de comprendre
comment fonctionne le processus
décisionnel, c'est-à-dire comment qu' un
un le problème du pouvoir, tu le
connais, c'est que tu es entouré de
courtisan. Ces courtisans, ils
t'expliquent toujours que oui, tu as
raison chef, quelle bonne idée chef.
Alors, selon la nature dictatoriale ou
démocratique du pouvoir, tu vas avoir
des gens qui vont plus ou moins
discuter. Mais si c'est la dictature, le
mec se lève le matin, il dit "Je vais
envahir le Kuwait." On lui dit "Oui
chef, quelle bonne idée chef." On aurait
dû y penser avant. Et donc, il va
envahir le Kuwait. Bon, donc tu vois le
tu vois le scénario le dans le cas des
démocraties, moi ce qui m'intéresse,
c'est cette sociologie de la de la
réflexion stratégique, c'est-à-dire tous
ces gens aujourd'hui tu vas te retrouver
avec une situation, regarde le cas de la
Libye, on a eu un personnage qui
s'appelait Bernard Ilvi
euh qui s'est payé au moment où
commençait déjà l'insurrection contre
Kaddafi, hein. Il se paye le voyage, il
arrive en contact avec les insurgés en
passant par la par le voyage, il a été
appelé par certaines minorités. Oui. Et
il paye le voyage parce qu'il a de
l'argent. Parce qu'il a de l'argent.
C'est ça qui est intéressant.
C'està-dire qu'il va se balader dans la
planète et il va dire "J'en viens, je
sais qui sont les gentils. Je sais
qu'ils sont les méchants." Et donc tu te
retrouves [raclement de gorge] avec une
situation où il va revenir pour
expliquer à Sarkozy que effectivement
là-bas, il y a une démocratie, il y a
une dictature qui va réprimer une
insurrection légitime et cetera et
cetera. Alors, il y a un fake news très
intéressant qui est la colonne de char
qui est en train de se diriger vers
Tripoli. La colonne de char étant
soi-disant qui va réprimer cette
insurrection de démocrates et cetera.
Donc, les avions français et anglais
avaient reçu une résolution on usienne
pour empêcher Kaddafi d'utiliser son
aviation. C'était une principe
d'interdiction de de décollage. Donc il
devait rester en l'air et empêcher toute
aéronef de décoller.
Ils reçoivent instruction non pas de
l'ONU mais des gouvernements français et
anglais d'empêcher cette fameuse colonne
de char d'arriver sur Tripolite. Et donc
ils vont commencer à faire des attaques
au sol. Et puis dans ces attaques au sol
effectivement Kadfis en tant que le la
chose tournait mal. Tu as vu la suite de
l'histoire, il essaie de sauver, il est
arrêté par les insurgés, il va être
lyché. Bon donc tu te dis aujourd'hui la
Libye est toujours dans une guerre
civile, le pays est toujours divisé en
morceaux. Et ben 2 ans après la guerre
civile, Henry Levi dans une dans une
interview dit tant mieux si j'y suis
pour quelque chose. Donc tu as ce que
j'ai appelé les intellectuels tfales,
c'est-à-dire les mecs sur qui aucune
critique n'accroche. Tu peux leur dire
vous aviez dit ça il y a 2 ans, regardez
la catastrophe. Il te dit non mais
j'avais raison il y a 2 ans, j'ai raison
aujourd'hui.
Farad, le l'effondrement de la Libye
en terme de génération de terrorisme, ça
a donné un peu beaucoup beaucoup.
Ça a permis de faire un territoire de
non droit. Ça a permis d'exfiltrer
l'armement de Kaddafi et d'armer
quelques minorités de
Est-ce que ça a découlé et dégouliné sur
l'Afrique centrale ? Est-ce que
je pense que enfin pour ce qui est de la
Libye et les conséquen au niveau du
terrorisme, je ne suis pas assez
compétent.
La Zawette
pour en parler, même si j'ai un certain
nombre d'idées que je vais exposer
brièvement.
Il y a d'abord le fait que
Kadavi était un dictateur sanguinaire,
tout le monde le savait, de même que
Saddam Hussein. Mais le problème c'est
que après la situation n'est pas
meilleure et même pire pour de
nombreuses raisons. D'ailleurs, ne
serait-ce que du point de vue de
l'intérêt occidental,
le fait que l'État libien
se soit effondré a fait que par exemple
il y a quand même une vague de migration
qui passe par la Libye et que un État
unifié ne serait en un sens limité.
Kaddafi avait prévenu, non ?
Kaddafi avait prévu, son fils avait
prévu. Oui, oui, oui, tout à fait.
Je veux dire que dans
[raclement de gorge] un sens euh est-ce
que les pays occidentaux ont le droit au
nom d'une légitimité supérieure à
dénoncer une dictature ? Oui ou non ?
Moi, je crois que non. Même si une
dictature évidemment je la condamne
[raclement de gorge] je la condamne
subjectivement, mentalement, mais en
supprimant ces dictatures,
la plupart des temps, le résultat est
beaucoup plus catastrophique
qu'auparavant en Irak, euh
Libye et ailleurs. Je veux dire, c'est
vraiment cette intervention
occidentale qui me paraît faire problème
parce que l'Occident n'est pas là en un
sens le dépositaire d'une légitimité
supérieure.
Est-ce que tu crois l'autoder juste
reviens une minute sur ce que dit Farad,
ce qui nous a convaincu de cette
nécessité de possession des moyens pour
faire la démocratie partout, ça a été la
guerre du golf. Pourquoi ? Parce que la
guerre du golf si tu veux invasion de
Saddam Hussein sur ce je cette
démocratie qui était le qui était le Kit
et donc en fin de la première guerre
post guerrefroide les Russes abstiennes
ont fait cette coalition 35 États qui
viennent pour libérer le Kit bref
guerre pré annoncée 6 mois de préavis on
avait donné la date où ça allait
commencer le match allait commencer
toutes les chaînes de la planète
viennent de s'installer en Arabie
Saoudite et donc tous les jours, il
fallait alimenter ces chaînes
d'information puisque rappelle-toi
c'était la scène et canen pour nous tous
les jours, il fallait qu'il y ait du
nouveau. d'un coup c'était la fille qui
s'était perdue dans le désert. Un coup
c'était la femme qui qui boxait un un
policier religieux et cetera. Bref,
quand le jour J arrive, on sait que la
guerre va commencer. Or, on a présenté
l'armée iraakienne comme la 4e armée du
monde. J'ai jamais su qui était la 3è,
mais en tout cas, celle-là, c'était la
4e. Et donc, cette armée va être réduite
en 120 he, c'est-à-dire en moins de 5
jours. Alors, on se dit "Mais attendez,
il y a trompie sur la marchandise, on
attendait un grand spectacle et tout à
coup l'armée ratiboisée." Bon, alors les
pays du golf empêche qu'on aille plus
loin, c'est-à-dire qu' ce sont les pays
du golf qui demandent qu'on s'arrête à
la frontière du Corite. Donc, nous en
revenons ivre.
Et il y a une manifestation aux
États-Unis qui est très intéressante.
C'est ce qu'on appelle le canagon des
héros. C'est la 5e avenue à New York où
les troupes victorieuses vont défiler.
Il y a un million de Américains qui
viennent pour le créer des ouras et
cetera parce que ça vengait le Vietnam.
C'est-à-dire qu'on avait lavé la défaite
du Vietnam. Là, on montrait que l'armée
américaine était respectueuse et cetera.
Mais après ça, on va être dans une
espèce de dynamique où on pense que la
solution militaire, parce qu'on en a les
moyens est toujours la solution. Et donc
on va avoir effectivement la
multiplicité d'intervention,
rappelle-toi la Somalie, on va
intervenir pour des raisons
humanitaires, pas stratégiques. On
raconte qu'il y a des chefs de guerre
qui p le convoi humanitaire. Ça c'est
scandaleux, on peut pas laisser faire.
Moi j'en parle avec Rony Broman, patron
de MSF à l'époque. Il me dit "Mais j'ai
appelé mes équipes sur place." Ils me
disent que les types qui attaquent les
convois ne sont pas des voleurs. Ils ne
revendent pas à l'aide parce qu'il la
distribu dans leur clan. Ils estiment
qu'ils sont mal servis. Donc si on
augmente le volume, on blesse on baisse
la conflictualité. Et ben pendant qu'il
est en train de plaider ça,
l'augmentation de l'aide, Kouchner,
lui-même ancien humanitaire devenu
ministre décide l'intervention. Et donc,
on se retrouve avec des des des troupes.
Tu sais que Saint-Jus disait personne
n'aime les missionnaires armés, les
Somaliens pas plus que les autres. Donc
les Américains veulent tenir le port de
Mogadicio parce que l'ide du manistère,
c'est du grand spectacle. Il faut
arriver en grand. Il manque de chance,
il y a un mec sur place qui s'appelle
Général Aidid qui a pas du tout
l'intention de laisser le contrôle de la
ville de Mogadicio. Quand les
hélicoptères vont faire une opération
commando sur lui, il va abattre deux
hélicoptères 20 G tuer les Américains
1920. Ils ne nous ont même pas informé
qu'il partait. Nous, j'entends nous
français, ils ne nous ont même pas dit
qu'il s'en allaient. Tu vois ce que je
veux dire ? C'est-à-dire la futilité de
l'intervention militaire par rapport à
la grosseur des moyens. Et donc on en a
on s'est arrêté, on a pensé que ce moyen
militaire était un moyen de résoudre les
crises. Or ça n'a jamais été une
solution. Voilà.
Fara Pierre, est-ce que vous sentez bien
les Jeux Olympiques à Paris en terme de
menaces terroristes ? Tout spectre
confondu.
Est-ce que vous allez rester à Paris ?
Est-ce que vous qui travaillez un petit
peu sur les questions de terrorisme,
vous sentez que on est un peu à la rue
en terme de détection, en terme de
planification, en terme de
reconnaissance ?
On ne sait jamais d'avance s'il va y
avoir une attaque ou non.
Alors euh
la prévisibilité
les Turcs, les Turcs, ils sont quand
même bien informés, hein.
Non, mais l'information a toujours des
failles. Hm
hm. et quelquefois même il y a pluralité
d'information contradictoire dont on ne
sait pas comment
choisir le bon grain de livret donc le
système d'information n'est jamais un
système impeccable
mais par ailleurs
si on regarde le nombre des attaques
djihadistes en Europe dans les dernières
années, on voit bien qu'il y a une
baisse sensible un peu dans tous les
pays européens hein et que le nombre des
tués est extrêmement réduit et souvent
les attaques sont le fait d'individu à
l'arme blanche
loup solitaire loup solitaire
ils sont jamais totalement solitaires.
Exactement. C'est pour ça que je je
n'utilise pas l'expression loup
solitaire parce que
le côté solitaire reste approuvé et
souvent il y a quelques-uns qui l'aident
et cetera mais disons que ce n'est pas
une attaque systématique d'un groupe
bien organisé et par conséquent les
limites sont jusqu'à présent du moins
dans les dernières années
[raclement de gorge]
assez réduite pour ce qui est du nombre
des morts. Mais cela ne signifie pas
pour autant qu'il n'y ait pas une
défaillance quelque part. Et donc en un
sens, je comprends l'angoisse des
organisateurs qui veulent boucler en
quelque sorte l'ensemble du système pour
qu'il n'y ait pas cela. Parce que s'il y
a une attaque terroriste réussie pendant
les Jeux Olympiques, évidemment cela
porte aussi atteinte à ce qu'on pourrait
appeler le prestige de l'État français
qui n'est pas capable d'assurer la
sécurité sur son propre territoire
pendant cette période limitée.
Juste une remarque sur ce que les deux
derniers attentats les plus effroyables
qu'on a eu en France, ça a été l'attaque
contre deux professeurs de
l'enseignement public.
Samuel [raclement de gorge] Patti,
l'auteur est un chechen qui avait le
statut de réfugié politique. Alors tu te
dis mais attends oui les chechen les
pauvres, ils sont massacrés par les
Russes. Donc le mec avait effectivement
un statut de réfugié politique. Le gosse
n'avait même pas ce prof là. Il demande
à ce qu'on lui fasse des signes.
Rappelle-toi que Samuel Pati avait
présenté les caricatures de Charlie
Hebda pour avec ses élèves pour en
discuter.
Le gosse va venir, il va se le faire
désigner, il va l'attaquer, il va le
décapiter.
Les les gendarmes quand les gendarmes
arrivent, ils la battent. Le père
Anzorov félicite son fils pour ce qu'il
a fait et toute la famille pour ses
clics et ses claques et rentre en tchen
alors je me suis dit tiens c'est marrant
j'aimerais voir le dossierorof à la con
nationale du droit d'asile.
Les amis qui y sont me disent "Mais
c'est impossible, il y a aujourd'hui des
on, tu ne peux pas t'opposer à une
candidature quel que soit le degré de
dangérrosité". Bon deuxème épisode,
cette fois ça le professeur Bernard tu
sais qui a été tué mais cette fois par
un ingouche. Alors tu te dis "Attends
entre la tetchen et l'ingoui je connais
pas la politique française dans la
région. Donc tu vois bien que tu as à
l'intérieur des trouées qui sont en
particulier le droit d'asile qui fait
que tout individu massacré chez lui a un
espèce de droit à venir se réfugier en
France quel que soit son degré de
dangérosité. Donc tu te rends compte que
notre le système est un système à trou.
Et
la promenade des anglais.
Ah bah la promenade des anglais c'est
encore autre chose parce que là la
promenade des anglais si tu veux le type
avait compris que finalement avec un
camion qu'il avait volé il pouvait tuer
autant de personnes qu'il voulaient.
Il avit fait du repérage un an avant.
Non.
Oui mais enfin tu sais sur la problème
des anglais ça va assez vite à repérer
hein
parce que c'était le feu d'artifice tout
le monde était là le mec a foncé dans le
tas. Alors, je pose cette question euh
pas totalement innocemment.
Quand Netaniaahu
reçoit de l'information que il y a le
Hamas qui est en train de préparer une
grosse attaque avec otage souhaité,
il [raclement de gorge] réagit pas. À
votre avis, c'est quoi ? C'est parce que
il se dit que l'information est pas de
bonne qualité. Il se dit que ça n'era
jamais. Il se dit que le mur ça va
protéger tout le monde. Il se dit que
c'est lui le meilleur et que ses
services sont les meilleurs.
Non, en fait le problème c'est que
il y a un contexte.
Le Hamas pendant les derniers mois avait
montré une sorte de propension à des
solutions
plus ou moins paisibles avec l'État
d'Israël. Et d'autre part, ce genre
d'information et je crois que les États
en reçoivent assez fréquemment.
C'est-à-dire que si on veut euh leur
donner crédit, il faut qu'on soit 24
heures sur 24, 365 jours sur 365
mobilisé.
Et alors,
c'est pas possible.
Pourquoi c'est pas possible ? parce que
euh c'est la les conséquences feront que
par exemple dans la société civile
elle-même, il va y avoir des réactions.
J'en ai marre le fait de marcher dans la
rue par exemple, que je sois restreint
dans mon mouvement et cetera. Euh ces
phénomènes-là sont beaucoup plus
complexes qu'on ne le pense. Mais je
crois qu'il y a d'un côté le sentiment
israélien d'une sorte de supériorité
écrasante qui faisait que Hamas ne
franchira jamais le pas qui est un
mauvais calcul mais en même temps est un
calcul qui est plausible.
Est-ce qu'une cit je vais citer un
exemple v par
une seule seconde.
Non mais parce que tu pour répondre à sa
question. Alors vas-y vas-y
tu sais pas comment ça se passe
quand il y a eu le génocide de Rwanda.
Si si, tu m'as expliqué 25 fois. Le mec
qui était censé expliquer le Rwanda il
c'était pas c'était pas le meilleur de
la salle. Vas-y, continu l'histoire du
Rwanda avec le conseiller qui
connaissait pas le Rwanda. Tu nous l'as
déjà expliqué ?
Non non, c'est pas ça que je voulais
dire. On a fait après avec mes
collaborateurs, on a repris tous les
télégrammes diplomatiques, toutes les
notes de la DGSE, toute la notes de la
DRM pour savoir ce que les autorités
politiques françaises avaient les moyens
de savoir. Est-ce que je t'ai raconté ça
ou pas ?
Alors le on tous les télégrammes
diplomatiques ça décrivait la vie
politique à Kigali comme si c'était le
5e arrondissement. Le parti républicain
machin va s'aler avec le Parti
socialiste machin. Bref, aucune aucune
alerte alors qu'il y avait dans les rues
des affiches, il faut écraser les
cafars. Bon donc tu te dis il y a une
sociologie où on fait gaffe parce qu'on
sait qu'il y a une chaîne France-Afrique
au-dessus de soi donc on va pas faire
prendre des risques et cetera. Rien dans
les télégram diplomatiques. La DRM
s'occupait du conflit dans l'Est.
C'était pas son boulot. la DGSE, une
note de la DGSE disant il se passe
quelque chose, on a du mal à savoir mais
tu es dans une hiérarchie. Donc le mec
qui est au-dessus de toi qui reçoit
cette note, il dit "Mais c'est bizarre,
il est le seul à le dire, je vais
peut-être attendre confirmation avant de
transmettre." C'est ça la sociologie de
la décision. C'est pas le fait qu'il y a
un mec intelligent qui va dire "On va
faire c, on va faire ça." Encore une
fois, c'est une faillite humaine autant
que
parce que les diplomates, il pouvaient
très bien dire "Mais il y a une espèce
d'ambiance qui appelle au massacre."
C'est un pays qui en avait connu
régulièrement. Tous les 10 ans, il y
avait un massacre au Rwanda. Et tu vois
que aujourd'hui, le seul pays qui
continue à se culpabiliser sur le Rwanda
alors qu'on a pas participé au génocide,
c'est la France. Donc va expliquer tout
ça.
Farad, euh pour résister au terrorisme
de
religieux ou politique,
est-ce qu'une démocratie est mieux armée
qu'une dictature ou c'est l'inverse pour
pouvoir éradiquer les mouvements
terroristes ? Une démocratie
a le privilège de pouvoir compter sur
les citoyens dans la menace terroriste.
Euh un pouvoir [raclement de gorge]
totalitaire
ne peut pas compter autant parce que
souvent lui-même il est soupçonné d'être
terroriste par moment, enfin et cetera.
Donc il y a un avantage du de la
démocratie sur le totalitarisme
sur ce point. Mais par ailleurs, la
capacité de répression d'un pouvoir
totalitaire est de manière impunie
et très largement supérieure à une
démocratie. Et puis d'autre part, il y a
aussi des phénomènes qui sont compliqués
si on les analyse hors contex. Je donne
un exemple. Euh en France et en Europe,
si un si un étranger
arrive et vit, mettons, entre 5 et 10
ans et montre une capacité de gérer sa
vie économiquement, socialement, sans
trop de dérapage, on lui accorde la
nationalité.
dans nombre de pays musulmans
actuellement en Iran, dans les pays du
Golfe, en Arabie Saoudite et cetera, on
peut rester 20 ans sans avoir cette
nationalité et tous les droits vous sont
refusés. Et par conséquent, euh il y a
un problème lié à ce qu'on pourrait
aussi la nature, on pourrait appeler
aussi la nature de la démocratie. euh
une démocratie. Euh moi-même je suis
critique euh de la démocratie au niveau
international, au niveau de
l'hégémonisme des États occidentaux et
cetera. Mais euh si on me demande à
choisir entre une démocratie déficiente
sur beaucoup de points comme on les a vu
dans l'analyse que nous avons faite et
une un totalitarisme qui parviendrait à
colmater les brèches de manière plus
efficace
localement et moi je choisirai la
démocratie. Et donc je pense que dans un
sens, on peut dire malgré toutes ces
défaillances, une démocratie si elle est
dirigée par des gens compétents, est
supérieure à un totalitarise. Par
exemple, Chirak, le fait de ne pas avoir
participé à la guerre en Irak me paraît
avoir été un choix politique extrêmement
euh extrêmement pertinent.
Le dernier geste golien de la diplomatie
française, il avait fait la guerre
Chiraq. Tu sais qu'il se disputait avec
J justement avaient fait tous les deux
la guerre d'Algérie. Ils avaient pas les
mêmes points de vue, c'était très
intéressant parce qu'ils savaient ce que
c'est qu'une guerre provoquait. Je
reviens une minute sur la fragilité des
démocraties face au terrorisme.
Rappelle-toi que quand même quand on a
le Hamas le 7 octobre et cetera, c'est
effroyable le massacre et cetera. Le
début de la guerre d'Algérie, c'est les
massacres à Constantine et à Colo. Viol
de femme, meurtre de bébé et cetera. Et
tu as la même réaction d'une grande
démocratie qui est ces gens-là sont des
terroristes, on peut pas discuter avec
eux, on envoie l'armée. Hm
hm. Tu vois ce que je veux dire ? Il a
fallu 8 ans pour se rendre compte que
derrière ces actes de violence, il y
avait une légitimité politique. On avait
réprimé les émeutes de ces tif
légitimité politique qui a massacré des
moues.
Mais la légitimité politique c'était la
revendication de l'indépendance des
Algériens. On avait répliqué aux émeutes
de cétif en tuant des mecs à la fin ces
types pour finalement à la fois
cristalliser qu'ils existaient parce que
si tu veux il y avait un mouvement
d'opposition qui demandait
l'indépendance mais ce mouvement il
était pas violent. Il a fallu passer à
l'acte de violence pour que tout à coup
la situation se cristallise. Et c'est il
y a aucune noblesse à ça. Mais tu sais
très bien que quand
Israël fait la répression à Gaza, moi je
connais pas de bombe qui fasse la
différence entre une femme, un enfant et
un terroriste. Donc si tu veux les
moyens de la répression donne
l'impression de la force que la force va
régler la question. Si si tu reconnais
pas la légitimité politique qu'il y a
derrière l'effroyable moment, c'est pour
ça qu'il y a ce débat en France sur le
thème le hama. Si vous les justifiez,
vous êtes machin, vous êtes ces
Farad pour pour des questions de
terrorisme, comment c'est perçu par le
pays, par exemple l'Indonésie,
comment s'est perçu pays musulmans comme
l'Indonésie que il y a des musulmans qui
se fassent taper dessus, que la bombe
qui fait une tonne fait pas de de
discernement entre un pauvre mot et un
terroriste et pas une femme. Comment
s'est perçu ?
C'està-dire [raclement de gorge]
pourquoi
est-ce que c'est irradiit chez eux ? Euh
le problème euh enfin je crois que c'est
un sujet qui mériterait vraiment un
traitement euh à part parce que il y a
autant de pays musulmans euh qu'il y a
euh de points de vue. Et puis par
exemple pour ce qui est de l'Indonésie,
c'est l'attaque terroriste contre cette
île où il y a eu [raclement de gorge]
plusieurs centaines voilà de morts qui a
fait que quand même c'est aussi un un
centre touristique qui fait vivre
énormément de gens et par conséquent le
résultat n'a pas été unanimement pour ce
terrorisme et même dans une très grande
mesure, il y a eu des il y a eu une
désapprobation. Je crois que c'est un
problème qui est lié aussi à des
contextes qu'on ne peut pas nier. Par
exemple, pour ce qui est de la
démocratie française et l'Algérie, on
voit bien qu'au début, il y a cette
espèce d'aveuglement face à ce problème
[raclement de gorge]
lié à l'indépendance algérienne qui
était douloureuse parce que l'Algérie
n'était pas une colonie normale, c'était
une colonie de peuple vent. Il y avait
quand même
plus d'un million de Français qui
habitaient là et qui avaient ce
sentiment que ce n'était pas comme le
Maroc ou comme la Tunisie. Donc il y a
aussi une histoire. Les démocraties ne
sont pas à l'abri de défaillance. Mais
disons que il y a eu quand même cette
prise de conscience en France de la
légitimité grandissante, ce qu'on
pourrait appeler du droit
[raclement de gorge] algérien à
l'indépendance qui dans un pays non
démocratique ne se serait pas produit
avec autant d'isance. Je veux pas dire
que il y a il y a eu des ratés, il y a
eu plusieurs années, il y a eu des
massacres, il y a eu quand même
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
morts.
On sait bien que ça a été en Algérie
quand même des massacres aussi du
gouvernement de de l'armée française qui
ne sont pas qui sont vraiment qui sont
vraiment condamnables au nom de droits
international
torture la torture en Algérie français.
Mais en même temps, il y a eu une prise
de conscience qui a été favorisée par le
fait que le pouvoir n'était pas
totalitaire en France. Si tu veux, le le
terrorisme, quand je dis que c'est un
moyen d'action et pas un ennemi, c'est
aussi un argumentaire qui te permet de
dire non, ça c'est bien et ça c'est pas
bien. Si tu veux sur le terrorisme,
c'est la vie des pays tiers qui est
important. Donc il y a ceux qui vont
reconnaître que le ha c'est une
résistance et ceux qui vont dire non pas
du tout, c'est un horrible massacre. Et
donc tu te retrouves dans
[raclement de gorge] une situation où
[grognement] si tu refuses de
caractériser chaque crise mais que tu la
qualifies de terroriste, tu n'en sors
pas. Je te prends l'exemple en Chine,
lesour font un attentat sur la
plastienne ademmen avec une voiture
piégée. Personne ne va dire que c'est du
terrorisme condamnable puisque c'est de
la lutte de libération. Tu vois, je veux
dire le qualificatif comment il est
utilisé dans un [raclement de gorge]
sens ou dans l'autre. Oh mais merde, les
gamins qui étaient à un concert qui se
sont fait massacrer avec des gars qui
ont débarqué à coup du LM. Ah mais c'est
une blague.
Mais qu'est-ce que tu veux que je te
dise ? Oui, c'est une blague. Je te dis
comme les massacres de Colo et de
Constantine au début de la guerre
d'Algérie. Tout le monde les a oublié
mais parce que depuis s'est passé 8 ans
de guerre, on a envoyé le contingent et
il a fallu au bout du compte arriver à
reconnaître que au bout de tout ça, il y
avait une légitimité politique qu'il
fallait prendre en compte. Moi, j'aime
beaucoup la phrase de Deul qui le 13 mai
58 sur la place du forum à Alger dit "Je
vous ai compris, il y a pas de phrase
plus ambigue que celle-là parce que tu
sais pas à qui il s'adresse. S'il
s'adresse aux Algériens pour leur dire
"Je sais que vous avez vous allez on va
aller vers l'indépendance ou au pied
noir sur le thème, vous inquiétez pas,
la répression va tomber."
Tu vois sur la l'habilité politique et
il fallait qu'il revienne au pouvoir
parce que la 4e République était
complètement perdue. Il y avait eu les
bombardement de Sakiat Sididi Youssef,
c'estàdire que la laiation française
avait bombardé un village tunisien.
Farad, j'aimerais que tu me parles de
terrorisme et d'extrême droite.
Enfin, je je suis impliqué dans un
travail de recherche avec des chercheurs
de l'Université de Toulouse à ce sujet
et donc on est au début de notre
recherche. Mais disons que
il y a l'extrême droite légaliste
qui n'est pas terroriste. Je veux dire
le Rassemblement national n'est pas
terroriste jusqu'à nouvel ordre. Enfin,
je veux dire, ce qu'ils font, c'est de
faire des débats au niveau de la société
euh même si on peut [raclement de gorge]
être en désaccord avec eux sur le plan
politique, mais il y a ce qu'on appelle
l'ultradroite
qui est qui a recours à la violence et
donc
l'ultra gauche aussi. l'ultra gauche
aussi, mais disons que toute proportion
gardée, il me semble encore une fois euh
point de vue qui peut être contesté euh
que l'ultradroite a le vent en poupe en
Europe et l'ultra gauche n'est pas aussi
dangereuse pour ce qui est de son côté
étendu. Quand quand quand vous dites
ultradooite, c'est ce que les Américains
euh appellent la menace vanille,
c'est-à-dire euh du petit blanc des
classé,
c'est-à-dire que la c'est c'est c'est
cette extrême droite qui a recours à la
violence physique,
son traîne à ce
dans la société, voilà, et pas seulement
à
des débats politiques. Voilà, c'estàdire
une intervention physique violente au
sein de la société civile. C'est ça
qu'on appelle enfin l'ultradroite et moi
je crois que actuellement pas seulement
en France mais un peu partout en Europe,
on voit bien qu'il y a d'abord un
système de droite légaliste qui a le
vent en poupe et que il y a aussi cette
espèce d'ultradroite qui est multiple
d'ailleurs qui n'est pas quand on dit
ultra droite c'est comme si c'était
unifié, ça ne l'est pas. C'est plusieurs
groupesuscules qui ont un certain nombre
de euh de convergences mais aussi des
divergences dans leur attitude, dans
leur vision. Euh et puis même il y a
apparemment il y a eu une sorte de
d'ultradroite ou euh extrême droite euh
chrétienne qui a été condamné d'ailleurs
par euh qui a été interdite par le
ministère de l'intérieur euh pour euh
euh pour son point de vue. Et donc moi,
je crois que vraisemblablement on est
dans des sociétés en Europe du moins et
même aux États-Unis où euh
l'ultradroite sera la forme
vraisemblablement encore une fois
dominante de violence terroriste entre
guillemets dans l'avenir.
D'autant que le le le terrorisme
d'extrême gauche a connu son apogé dans
la décennie 70. C'était l'époque où en
Italie il y avait la l'armée rouge, la
brigade armée rouge, il y avait la rot
armée frac. Quelle année ça ?
Dans du grosso modo, c'est post 68.
C'est en même temps que les réseaux
Gladi Pas du tout.
Non non non parce que les réseaux
Gladio, c'est l'instrumentalisation par
la police de des de ces explosions si tu
veux de cette violence d'extrême gauche.
Donc tu vas avoir un peu partout en
Europe, y compris en France, y compris
en Allemagne, y compris en
c'est quoi les réseaux gladios Pierre ?
Les réseaux gladios, c'était pas ceux
qui voulaient aider le l'extrême gauche
à commettre des attentats, c'est-à-dire
comment ils les ont instrumentalisé.
Moi, je me souviens pas de ça.
On va te laisser euh te faire fa checker
euh par la communauté.
Écoute, ça je m'en fous de toute façon.
Peu importe, ce qui m'intéresse, c'est
la fraction armée rouge
et puis voilà, la multiplicité
c'était action directe. Cit, c'était
action directe.
Oui. Mais qui était beaucoup plus faible
que les brigades rouges en Italie. En
Italie, c'est ça qui était le plus
important où fait fraction armée en
Allemagne.
Absolument. Et donc si tu veux, tu as eu
un terrorisme d'extrême gauche qui lui a
eu des formes extrêmement violentes et
lui aussi se marquait par son
fractionnement.
Mais oui,
parce que il y avait pas d'unité si tu
veux, c'était une unité d'intérêt par
selon les circonstances avec parfois
collaboration de la police notamment en
Italie pour les amener à faire des
attentats de façon à pouvoir les arrêter
ensuite. Et donc on est sur quelque
chose si tu veux qui a qui a connu son
paroxisme et qui après a décliné.
Maintenant, on est plutôt sur une montée
d'un terrorisme d'extrême gauche
[raclement de gorge] et pareil, c'est
d'extrême droite, pardon, mais c'est
vraiment effectivement fractionné en
petitte unités. Il y a pas de il y a pas
d'homogénéité si tu veux de l'action.
Et puis effectivement, les ces vont être
variés. Ça peut être effectivement de
tuer un musulman, ça peut être de de
tenter d'assassiner un homme politique
et cetera.
Farad, est-ce qu'il y a un sujet que tu
que vous souhaiteriez qu'on aborde
ensemble ou où vous pouvez me donner
trois livres à conseiller à ma
communauté, à notre communauté ?
Enfin, pour ce qui est de
mes préférences actuelles,
ça porte sur la philosophie
spiritualiste et donc je ne crois pas
que ce soit d'actualité par rapport au
propos que nous avons tenu en ce moment.
Pourquoi ? parce que je travaille sur
cette sur une philosophie
liée à la pensée [raclement de gorge]
de Michel Henri, de Merlot Ponti, de
Rich Krishna Murti,
de Krishna Murti
euh
pas autant mais disons que
personnellement c'est plutôt cette
philosophie phénoménologique
franco-allemande qui m'a toujours
inspiré et sur laquelle je travaille et
avec une inspiration littéraire et Donc,
mais par contre, on peut penser à des
ouvrages que je vous communiquerai par
la suite sur les phénomènes de violence,
de terrorisme,
de djihadisme sur lesquels j'ai
travaillé et que je continue à
travailler euh
avec des groupes de chercheurs.
Comment s'appelle votre dernière votre
dernier livre que personne ne lit ? En
fait, euh je crois que en tant que
intellectuel euh
un peu désœuvré et
avec un ressenti euh d'être incompris
par la société, ce qui est ce qui est un
peu ce qui est un peu le cas de 99 % des
intellectuels.
Ah non, ça dépend lesquels. Il y a des
intellectuels médiatiques qui ont une
chronique
1 % 1 % mettons enfin un peu plus enfin
bon, il pense qu'il y en a un peu plus.
Bon euh il y a j'ai fait un livre en
coédition avec en en co participation
avec Jérôme Ferré et puis un groupe de
chercheurs, une grande partie
toulousaine mais aussi parisienne sur
Family and Jihadism in France. Ça a été
publié il y a un an et demi.
En français, ça donne quoi ?
La famille et le djihadisme en France.
le rôle de la famille dans le djihadisme
parce que le djihadisme français alors
on se focalise sur les personnalités
charismatiques de ces groupesl
dont ils ont construit une vision entre
l'idéologie et l'anthropologie et le
fait que il faut pas se centrer
uniquement sur les individus mais aussi
sur le contexte global dans lequel il se
situent au et donc ce travail de groupe
qui n'est pas le mien seul c'est même
encore une fois, on est une dizaine de
personnes à avoir fait ce livre
nous a beaucoup inspiré puisque ça a été
fait en anglais et personne ne veut que
la traduction française soit publiée
parce qu'il pensent que maintenant c'est
dépassé.
Question
pour aller dans le sens de ce que tu
dis. Le jeune Anzorov qui va tuer Samuel
Patti arrive en France à l'âge de 2 ans.
Il va faire l'école républicaine
puisqueil a 12 ans quand il va
assassiner Samuel Patti. Il s'est donc
radicalisé dans sa famille. Il s'est pas
radicalisé à l'école républicaine. Or,
[raclement de gorge] tu le vois bien, le
père le félicite et finalement toute la
famille rentre au enchini. Donc tu vois
bien que effectivement ce milieu
familial là, c'est un noyau dur dans
lequel il est très difficile de pénétrer
et tu vas avoir des phénomènes encore
une fois qui n'ont pas de rapport avec
la société française. Les tchéchenes,
c'était pas la politique française en
tchen qui pouvait expliquer ça, tu vois.
Oui, il y a Mera, la famille Merra,
l'éclin. Enfin bon, je veux dire, il y a
des groupes où la famille joue un rôle
fondamental, que ce soit la famille
réelle ou la famille imaginaire,
c'est-à-dire finalement une sorte
d'extension imaginaire de la famille euh
qui dépasse en quelque sorte l'éclibrage
normal ou bien une famille à
reconstituer que nous avons appelé d'un
commun accord la néoa, c'est-à-dire
l'imaginaire d'un islam qui se construit
en quelque sorte en opposition à la
société française dans un rapport
conflictuel où la violence devient
totalement légitime.
Farad, est-ce que vous êtes appelé ou
écouté par
nos politiques qui vous demandent des
conseils, nos services de renseignement
qui vous demandent des conseils ? un
intellectuel euh sauf s'il est vraiment
[raclement de gorge] euh le fils d'un
milliardaire, je ne cite pas de nom, euh
est souvent euh dans un état
d'insatisfaction congénitale par rapport
à ce qu'on pourrait appeler le fait de
d'être écouté ou non. Un intellectuel,
c'est un prophète incompris par essence.
aucun pouvoir, seulement la légitimité
de sa parole. Et comme les intellectuels
se sont démultipliés par rapport au
temps de Zola, on n'est plus on n plus
l'étoff d'un zolard. On est des
médiocres, enfin dans mon cas personnel
et on sent que si on est médiocre, c'est
que la société ne nous prend pas au
sérieux.
Je connais bien ce sentiment. Pierre,
est-ce qu'il y a un sujet que tu
aimerais aborder avec nous ? notre
communauté où est-ce que tu as trois
bouquins à nous conseiller.
Je sais pas comme ça tout de suite en
tête trois bouquins. Enfin, il y en a au
moins deux. Il y a celui de BNB que j'ai
cité qui s'appelle silence religieux sur
la façon dont la gauche
en terme de sujet. Tuas tu as un sujet
que tu souhaites aborder avec nous ?
Oui, moi il y a un sujet qui me qui
m'intéresse beaucoup, c'est quand même
le rôle des intellectuels dans la
société française. Parce que
[raclement de gorge]
je t'en cite un autre exemple que j'ai
peut-être déjà cité dans dans des
interviews. C'était le cas de Alexandre
Adler. Non, il est malade. Je t'ai dit.
Non, il est mort. Il est mort. Merde !
Donc Alexandre Adler était un type
intéressant parce que si tu veux quand
on crée la délégation aux affaires
stratégiques, on le trouve dans les
meubles parce qu'il avait été recruté
par le cabinet précédent et donc on fait
une réunion sur la Turquie, je sais plus
pourquoi. Enfin bref, il était là donc
il participe et Alexandre était un
compteur ce qui est une dimension
importante de la même façon que BHL est
un écrivain. Adler est un compteur et
donc il prend la parole et il commence à
dire il y a l'instruction du KGB de
telle date qui a été reprise d'ailleurs
en 63 et puis après il y a celle de 58
et cetera.
Je me tourne vers le mec de la DGSE, je
lui dis "Ben c'est intéressant ce qu'il
raconte, vous les avez ces instructions
?" Le tube sans tourner la tête me dit
"Non, il invente."
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ? Ça veut
dire que si tu es un intellectuel,
si tu as un intellectuel tfâ, tu as ta
place dans cette société. Si tout à coup
tu interpelles le politique en disant
"Non, on est sur quelque chose de plus
grave, de plus dur, de plus compliqué,
tu ne peux pas participer au débat
politique. Tu peux participer au
C'est pour ça qu'ils ont été
complètement borgnes dans le meilleur du
des cas avec la guerre avec les Russes.
Tu parles de qui là ? Des intellectuels
? De qui ? Ou des
des intellectuels qui sont censés
conseiller ou ne pas influencer ?
Mais ils conseillent pas les
intellectuels. C'est en ça que tu
trompes. Je te dis le mécanisme
décisionnel, tu ne le connais pas parce
qu'on raisonne tous en se disant "Oui,
mais il y a des gens intelligents,
diplômés et cetera qui ont pris telle
décision pour telle et telle raison."
Moi, j'ai assisté à des réunions dans
lesquelles on ne prenait une décision
sans connaître le sujet.
C'est lunaire,
pardon.
C'est lunaire.
C'est lunaire. Mais bien sûr. Mais en
même temps, l'homme politique
aujourd'hui, puisqu'il y a plus l'URSS,
l'homme politique, son problème c'est la
sa réélection, c'est pas la gestion de
la crise. Donc si j'envoie du soldat,
est-ce que je gagne des voix ? Écoute,
quand tu penses à un personnage comme
Hollande 500 morts dans les rues de
Paris, il parle de la déchéance de
nationalité puis tout à coup, il ref il
recule. Tu te dis "Attends, c'est ça
qu'on a nommé comme président de la
République ? Alors que la déchéance de
nationalité est inscrite dans la
constitution, il pouvait effectivement
définir les conditions de la déchéance.
Encore une fois, si s'agissait pas de
faire de la faire perdre la nationalité
française des gens qui n'avaient que la
nationalité française, il s'agissait de
leur faire perdre la nationalité
française à des binationaux. Et donc tu
te dis mais cet individul aujourd'hui
ressort, il va se présenter à des
circonscriptions pour pouvoir retrouver
une parole politique.
Faut casser la machine de production des
élites quoi. Il y a quelque chose qui
qui a quelque chose de pourri au royaume
de Danemark comme disait.
Donne-moi trois bouquins.
Écoute, je te dis donc le bouquin de
Bernard Bum, j'en ai je suis en train
d'en lire un autre qui s'appelle le euh
la tyrannie de la pénitence de Bruckner,
je crois. Et je t'en trouverai un
troisème. Mais si tu vois, je suis dans
cet état d'esprit aujourd'hui où
j'essaie de me demander pourquoi
aujourd'hui avec les LGBTQ, si tu veux,
tu as une espèce de discours de la
victimisation qui fleurit et qui se
multiplie. On sait pas qui sont les plus
plus mais enfin on en attend plein qui
explique tous qu'ils ont été victimes et
que s'ils ont victimes, ils ont le droit
si tu veux à la reconnaissance et
cetera. Pense-toi, pense fou.
Attends, attends, attends. Ouais, ça
dépend si c'est les cus. Je sais pas
c'est les mecs qui savent pas s'ils sont
ni femmes. Qu'est-ce que tu veux faire
pour eux ? Tu vas leur faire une
troisième porte dans les chiottes pour
qu'ils puissent y aller. Il y a pas de
problème pour les cuissons. Ni un ni
l'autre. Tu veux qu'on dis fasse ? C'est
pas un problème de politique publique.
Enfin, moi je pense politique publique.
Je pense pas. Si tu as si tu te sens pas
bien, ben très bien, mais est-ce que
pour autant tu vas interpeller le
pouvoir politique en disant
"Ecoupez-vous de mon cœur ?" Donc si tu
veux sur le sujet là aujourd'hui, en
gros le basculement il se fait si tu
veux avec la création d'État d'Israël.
C'est-à-dire que en Israël, on reconnaît
qu'il a eu un massacre juif qui a été un
des plus effroyables qui existait. Et
donc il y a un droit à compensation. On
va reprendre un fil historique que tu
connais, c'est "Nous étions ici il y a
2000 ans, donc prenez vos affaires et
partez." Ce discours est repris dans un
certain nombre de cas aujourd'hui,
c'est-à-dire vous êtes et cetera et
cetera. Donc si tu veux avec après ça,
tu vas l'avoir avec les décolonisations,
c'est-à-dire effectivement euh on a
droit à notre territoire et cetera et
cetera. Donc si tu veux si tu commences
à entrer dans ce discours de la
victimisation et que la victimisation
ouvre un droit à réparation, regarde le
cas de cet historien qui s'appelle
Olivier Pérez Grenouillot. Il avait cré
un boucage sur les traites négrières,
c'est-à-dire qu'il avait parlé de la
traite le commerce angulaire, de la
traite intrafricaine et de la terre sur
la la traite sur la côte est.
Et il dit mais en fait la traite le
commerce s'est arrêté un siècle plus tôt
que les autres. Bon effectivement ça
n'empêche que c'était une horreur,
c'était effroyable, tout ce que tu veux
et cetera. Mais le commerce intrafricain
se poursuit encore aujourd'hui. Encore
aujourd'hui, il y a même du savage
intrafricain.
Intraafricain. Oui. C'està-dire qu'il y
a de l'eslavage pour dette encore en
Afrique. Et puis tu as le commerce sur
la côte est le commerce sur la côte est
avait comme plateforme de départ
Zanzibar. Dans Dimar était l'un des
grands euh lieux de trafic d'esclaves.
C'est une partie des hommes étaient
partis là-bas pour faire des ENUC tu
veux pour les haremes. Donc c'est quand
même pas très respectueux des droits de
l'homme quand même si on y réfléchit
bien. Et donc ce commerce lui-là s'est
arrêté encore plus tard et ben il a été
attaqué par le comité représentatif des
associations noires de France parce
qu'on l'a accusé de faire du
révisionnisme et relativiser la traite.
Il y a eu une levée de bouclier des
historiens en disant "Mais il y en a
marre. La recherche scientifique, c'est
pas une recherche idéologique. Si vous
comprez son mon argumentaire, il faut
sortir des arguments scientifiques et du
coup le cran a retiré sa plainte. Est-ce
que tu as un conseil pour les jeunes
générations ? Pierre
là
là.
Allez voter. Attends j'arrive.
Ah tu parles du vote là ?
Non non non pas pas du vot.
Ah ouais d'accord. Non écoute non j'ai
pas de conseil. Le coup du vieux con qui
donne des conseils si tu veux c'est
c'est un mythe littéraire ça. C'est
vrai. Bon
on va demander à Fara qui est un peu
moins con et un peu plus jeune. Farad.
Oui.
Est-ce que tu as Est-ce que vous avez un
conseil pour les jeunes générations, une
bouteille à la mer, quelque chose
d'impérissable et peut-être trois livres
avant qui ont été important dans votre
vie ?
En fait, pour ce qui est du conseil, euh
d'abord les livres, d'abord les livres.
Non, je les livres c'est pas évident
hein.
Trois livres qui ont été vachement
importants dans votre vie. Ça peut être
en qui ont été très important dans ma
vie
dans la construction de votre
personnalité, dans votre façon de penser
un bouquin qui vous a changé. Ça peut
être un
Monarcisme m'empêche de donner trois
titres. À mon avis, il faudrait plutôt
30. OK.
Je veux dire, c'est très difficile de
dire trois livres. Le chiffre 3, bon,
c'est la Trinité. Bon, on voit très
bien, il a la troica.
Euh bon bref, j'ai du mal enfin à donner
trois titres, mais vraisemblablement euh
bon, il y a Durkaim qui a fait un très
beau livre, il s'appelle Le Sacré.
Euh il y a [raclement de gorge]
Max Weber et son livre sur euh le
protestantisme et le capitalisme euh
sur la violence.
Euh sur la violence, il y en a plusieurs
àent.
Il y a aussi son son premier mari qui
avait fait un comment il s'appelle
levenu qui est devenu nazi en fait. Non
non non pas du tout. Qui a fait vraiment
il a travaillé beaucoup sur le nucléaire
qui a vraiment dénoncé l'inconséquence
des sociétés occidentales. Ah oui et
puis moi j'étais j'étais un disciple de
Heidegger. Donc euh évidemment euh ce
qu'il a fait par la suite
euh euh en souscrivant à un certain
nombre de thématiques qui avaient quand
même
qui faisait écho au naazisme,
évidemment, ça pose un problème et de
même que quelqu'un comme Céline qui est
un grand écrivain mais qui a été qui a
été salot pour ce qui est de
l'antisémitisme et du rejet
des juifs sous une forme inacceptable.
Il y a aussi Prou, il y a Prou aussi
pour moi. Pour moi Prou c'est le grand
dans les films américains que le héros
est pur de bout en bout. Quand est-ce
qu'on
C'est intéressant le cas de Céline comme
le cas d'idegger parce que il y a que
dans les films américains que le mec est
un vrai pur, dur et de bout en bout que
les mecs et des et des façades si tu
veux complexes et cetera dans lesquelles
ils se sont trompés sur leur situation,
c'est à la fois leur grandeur et leur
misère. Mais en même temps, il bar même
temps, on en vient à se poser la
question de savoir comment on peut être
aussi génial qu'un Heidegger ou qu'un
qu'un un Cline
alors que c'est de la le dès qu'il
s'agit de parler d'un certain nombre de
thématiques que l'homme honnête le plus
élémentaire dans sa son éducation
condamnerait. Enfin bon, je veux dire,
il y a quelque chose dedans quelque
chose d'incompréhensible. Une question
personnelle, un recueil de poèmes perse.
Ah, le grand qui m'a vraiment
personnellement
touché et même influencer, c'est quand
même Roui, le grand Roui avec des poèmes
qui sont extraordinaires.
Quand on le lit, on ne peut pas rester
insensible. C'est par exemple
quand on lit un certain nombre de verre
de verline, il y a une sonorité qui est
aussi importante sinon davantage que le
contenu. Et
et la version traduite est bien traduite
ou il faut apprendre le Perse ?
Il est intraduisible. C'est comme les
grands par exemple. Comment veut-on
traduire Berlin en une autre langue ou
encore pire malarmé ? Je crois que c'est
impossible. La traduction est une
trahison et en même temps euh c'est
important, il y a des traductions qui
tentent de se rapprocher ou par exemple
dont la traduction euh anglaise par Fitz
Gerald euh inspire en quelque sorte euh
la poésie de Rayam mais sous une forme
très anglaise mais en trahisant.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Farad,
voyager.
Non, faites de la poésie, ne faites pas
la guerre plutôt que faire l'amour parce
que l'amour est quand même, il y a le
danger avec le sida et tout ça. Faites
de la poésie plutôt que la guerre.
Préservatif maintenant Farade.
Oui, mais la c'est un acte si tu veux
tellement trivial maintenant avec les
préservers. Faire l'amour, je veux dire
faire l'amour est différent de l'amour.
Faire l'amour, c'est vraiment de la pure
sexualité. Bon, faites l'amour mais
c'est une banalité extrême. Ça ne
regarde personne que vous. Mais par
contre, faire la poésie, c'est autre
chose.
Est-ce qu'on se prend en ver tous les
trois et qu'on discute de poésie ?
Poésie, littérature littérature. Ah oui.
Ah oui,
messieurs, merci Pierre.
Merci à toi.
Au plaisir. Merci beaucoup.
[musique]